and what's happening brother how are you
hey Joe yeah it's great to be here
thanks for having me I've been following
your exploits on social media and the
yellow caiman yes dude that is a wild
looking creature isn't it it's
unbelievable it was thought to be
extinct yes so this one's it's a little
confusing it um it's a species that was
last seen in when the last one died in a
zoo in the 80s and because of the region
that it occupies in Colombia which has
always been controlled by FARC rebels
nobody had been back down there to look
for it and myself and there's actually
this amazing Colombian scientist named
Sergio Rianna we're both kind of going
and prodding and trying to see if we
could get in and we both found it within
a month of each other oh wow yeah now it
was a beautiful looking creature look at
that thing right it's such a wild green
yellow color so wow it's you super
unique didn't just holding that thing by
the neck yeah we just had a little
wrestling match him and I so you don't
even have body control don't you want to
take Mountain here maybe get a back
mount get some hooks in you know
reptiles they tire out so they're not
like mammals once they expend all their
energy that's kind of it but yeah
absolutely amazing are they similar to
regular crocodiles alligators and that
they don't have to eat for like a year
yeah though so caiman
I mean caiman don't have the as slow of
metabolism as certain other species but
they are they're a member of the
alligator family so to speak and they
can go very long times without food what
a crazy animal like looks like a monster
yep I mean look at the teeth on that
thing
swallows things basically hold yeah it
spins to take chunks off of things
swallows them whole it doesn't have to
eat for a year
can go underwater for how long without
holding it's like 4045 minutes some of
them yes no ideas there right this is
waiting for you and they're fairly small
right there's like a 90 pound animal
when it's fully grown well these ones
it's so little is known about this
particular species of caiman that it's
hard to say I would say yeah a hundred
pounds is probably about right there's a
great photo Jaime from the nature is
metal Instagram page from yesterday
that's nuts I love that page there's a
great one of a Jaguar with a caiman in
its mouth that one look at the eyes on
that [ __ ] yeah go look at that look at
those bangs right in the throat like
just death grip and then you can see
that that came in is death rolling in
that scene right it's trying to get away
it's rolling and that jag is just locked
in the eyes on that thing my god
unbelievable
it's like Nature has created like in
those kind of eyes that's the perfect
that's the the perfect vision of terror
yeah like those eyes like locked into
those eyes like there's no forgiveness
there's no emotions there's just
ferocity and aggression and death it
seems like nothing but testosterone is
behind that you know I mean testosterone
is probably the wrong wrong chemical but
it just seems so focused and motivated
and like you say it's just it looks like
death yeah I'm sure there's some
testosterone involved in that equation
too but it's a bunch of other cat [ __ ]
literally apparently the thing in the
caption was saying that the caiman has
one of the greatest bites per pound of
any of the big cats and they regularly
eat these the Jag yeah Jaguar rather has
one of the greatest bites and they
regular eats these these Caymans yeah no
they're amazing and and you know back to
the one that we found it's so great
because like I'm the hide-and-seek guy
right like I look for them and now
there's a scientist Sergio Rhianna down
in Colombia who's gonna manage that
species ongoing existence oh wow it's
really cool so what is involved in that
like managing their existence what is he
I mean you know it's wildlife management
so it's it's getting proper population
dynamics trying to understand them
genetically figure out what their food
sources figure out how much hunting
pressure they can take or cannot take
those kind of things and that's not my
department you know I go in and look for
them that's someone like Sergio who's in
the field lives in Colombia can work
with the species it's really cool I
remember there was a documentary about
this guy who was a scientist who was
obsessed it was a biologist he was
obsessed with the giant sloth and he was
spending all of his time down the Amazon
he had been down there for years and the
the
the documentary was following him at
this stage where he was getting really
frustrated and not sure if he's wasting
his career right like there was this
feeling like [ __ ] this thing might not
be real yeah
like cuz they were telling ya I saw it
it's over the hill you sure you saw it
right and they you know they bring these
people in they would speak their native
tongue and they'd have this discussion
of this thing that they saw yep two
years ago yeah big like a bear walks on
its hind leg megatherium yeah there we
discussed this briefly last time I saw I
think it's funny we go straight back to
the same let's say well ha life stuff
but ya know it's who knows right who
knows if it's still out there there's
definitely ongoing reports so much so
that I forget what university but some
university actually launched an an
expedition to try and find the
Megatherium so really I'd have to look
it up probably 10 years ago now not that
long ago but but you know if an academic
institution is putting resources behind
an expedition like that there's a lot of
faith and maybe even Intel that they're
not releasing publicly to say this
animals still here wow that would be
crazy
that big was a giant sloth well there's
a couple varieties like there was a
North American one that was enormous
like bigger than a grizzly bear Wow
yeah but so from what I've been what
I've heard what I've read you're talking
about saying that stands 14 foot tall
walking around the Amazons like like the
14 foot tall like winter here's then a
Kodiak grizzly that's what the reports
say that's exactly I mean you got to
take their existence with a grain of
salt like but this page whatever this
page is a Bigfoot cousin and look up
there Megalodon sightings is the mega
dog shark still alive yeah and straight
away that's like discrediting you're a
you're like okay what is this website
you pull up there there's a article from
in June about just lots of information
about them it's not even saying like it
exists it's just saying this is all the
information we have about this this a
mapinguari sightings people love finding
undiscovered or mythical creatures to
turn out to be like the tasmanian tiger
right like that's a perfect example but
people they love to try to fight what is
the thylacine I'm saying yeah people
love to try to find that thing
idea that it's out there it's like what
is it about people where it's so
compelling to find a species that we
were we thought didn't exist or we
thought was extinct like whether it's
Bigfoot or the Loch Ness monster or the
thylacine which we know used to be real
right right
I mean what do you think I think that
people quite you know they long for the
unknown and there's this big question
mark surrounding cryptids or surrounding
extinct animals as to whether it's still
out there and that's so much more
inviting to the general to the general
populace
to get an answer to then knowing oh you
know there's 700 of them left and we're
trying to get them up to 1400 or
whatever the species dynamic is for some
other animal as opposed to being like
there could be one out there where is it
and I personally I've been on two
different expeditions looking for
thylacine really yeah yeah yeah I did
one in northern Australia up north of
Cannes and then one I spent a couple
weeks in Tasmania with a amazing
biologist Nick Mooney who he's adamant
that he's seen thylacine and he's a
biologist this isn't you know someone
who worked as a biologist that was out
in the wilderness going yeah yeah I've
seen thylacine and he was terrified to
tell everybody and that that tells me
that it's more credible right if you're
scared to tell people because of your
reputation as opposed to like going out
there going I saw it I saw it I saw it
right that becomes more credible than
the people who are just waving their
arms in the air go and I told you it's
here when did he come out of the
thylacine closet I'm scared to tell
people when I'm not sure if he told us
first or if it was public right before
then but not long ago
I mean maybe 10 years ago yeah that's
such a cool-looking animal too because
it was a marsupial tiger right yeah
sucio predator it's like a marsupial
wolf with tiger stripes it's so bizarre
and it had this amazing jaw that would
open like like a snake's like way wider
than its head should stripes on the back
just such a cool animal yeah and the
last one died in a zoo right the last
one that we think yep in Hobart in
Tasmania but let me let me lay this on
yeah so my next expedition for that
animal cuz I'm like all those other
people that are kind of obsessed with it
my next expedition for that animal is to
Papua New Guinea
so this species yeah that's right this
is this species used to range all the
way from Papua New Guinea down through
mainland Australia and into Tasmania
when people came over and settled that
area they brought with them dogs dingoes
and dingoes out competed them in
mainland Australia and possibly in Papua
New Guinea 4000 years ago but the the
thylacine remained in Tasmania where
there are no dingoes to out-compete them
but in mainland Australia you've got a
diversity of habitats so there are
places the thylacine could still hide
but in Papua New Guinea the terrain is
so crazy that the idea is that in
certain regions dingoes could have never
made it there so perhaps there's these
isolated regions where thiolate very
small thylacine populations continued
for the past four thousand years
have there been sightings many but just
the same kind of sightings is a giant
slot you know what I mean it's all
hearsay
we're so full of [ __ ] yes they are such
a problem if you're gonna be a guy like
you actually looking for species yeah
you got it you got to wade through so
much [ __ ] you know it's just and
it's funny because one thing can
discredit the entire story that maybe it
shouldn't because they're embellishing
or or you can be on the hook for
someone's story and be like I totally
believe this guy it's it's all real and
it could be complete BS and it's just so
hard to tell you just have to go with
instinct but it is incredibly compelling
I mean if you really did get an absolute
photograph of a thylacine and you knew
it was real or captured one yeah I think
I think it would be the you know
discovery of the century and I think it
would kind of shift the scales for
people that are on the fence about why
do I care about conservation what I care
about wildlife management you know those
kind of things to be like check this
animal out something that you know last
saw when we put a bounty on its head and
now it's back like it's hung on by a
thread like that's such a message of
hope you know let's save it let's bring
it back yeah well the whole environment
in Australia is so strange and now
because of the wildfires you know
there's a lot of species like those we
were just talking the other day about
the koala bears yeah that the koala
bears a lot of their habitat got burnt
you know a lot of
fires really sad really said there's on
fire and they're like losing it's awful
but there's such a little cute little
animal they are but and I don't have a
lot of first-hand experience with them
my understanding is they're actual jerks
like they're really cute and cuddly
looking but their behavior is pretty
aggressive and jerkish and I don't know
enough about them to really comment on
it but my understanding is it's kind of
like sea otters right do you know about
this thing with sea otters what about
them so like everybody loves sea otters
are so cute they're so cuddly sea otters
are super destructive they rape each
other like they're they're like gnarly
animal they're like not that sweet at
all isn't that everything with pandas
too like pandas are ruthless yeah
totally yeah but you look at him you're
like oh yeah miss sweetiepie
my youngest daughter is really into
polar bears
oh yes polar bears are adorable and she
wanted to get like a stuffed polar bear
and I find it so fascinating that that
animal which is the most ruthless of all
bears for sure we associate with
Klondike bars and coca-cola that's
everybody's buddy and they're sliding
around the snow and I almost want to
like show her like this is what they do
to seals right go on go up there and
just show a video I want to show her I
know she's not looking it yeah yeah like
that picture there's this image of this
seal and the they all have red faces
from blood what did they ever do they
ever figure out that one polar bear that
was in Russia that had been sprayed it
said like t-34 on it you see it in that
image right there that one Jamie I don't
know about that
right there someone had spray-painted T
and the number 34 on the side of a
bear's body and they don't know what
happened that's extremely ballsy
it's a spray-painted polar but how do
they do it and then the real concern is
that this bear is going to have a real
hard time hunting because they're gonna
be able to see it much better because of
the fact that it has the spray paint on
the side of it I've never I've never
seen this story before it's really yeah
they don't know they have no idea what
happened here it is Russian scientists
search for polar bear with black t-34
spray painting on its side cruel joke
can turn deadly
for a predator now too visible for both
prey and poachers right yeah do they
have a hard time with D they have a real
issue with certain towns in Siberia that
elect on the outskirts where polar bears
are invading mmm and they have like
dozens of polar bears entering their
towns they they've even evacuated towns
because of so many polar bears being
there from what I've heard would you
imagine just having an army of polar
bears roll into town you have a town of
like 150 people and in come eight polar
bears one day it's like what what can
you do it's nothing they're gonna kill
them you're gonna shoot them with rifles
are you gonna get out right you probably
should just get out yeah you should get
out yeah I mean it's polar bears
estranging I like bears in general or
strange animal because people love them
because we grew up with teddy bears
right and we see yogi and there's like
they're so lovable yeah on television
and the movies yeah and so people have
this idea of them like they want to take
bear selfies like hey take a bear selfie
like how many people get Jack taking
bear selfies yeah no that's a real thing
I have been contacted by people being
like hey why don't you like not pose
with wildlife because it's influencing
other people to do that I'm like I'm a
biologist it's my job I'm gonna have
another option here like I have to pose
with wildlife like I'm working with it
like I said post it you are the guy the
guy posted like maybe instead don't do
what I do you know don't just jump out
and try get a selfie with say that's
gonna kill you I think it's common sense
you have that whole idea of like that
what you're doing is influencing people
to do the same thing like alright well
you know come on
I think it's nuts I mean yeah do you
know how many pages on Instagram are
there where people are chugging vodka
and jumping off roofs and slamming
tables and all this other stuff so yeah
is everybody looking at being like hey
I'm gonna jump off a roof onto a table
yeah there's so many of those pages yeah
so many of those videos right people
breaking their legs jumping off
balconies like oh just don't do it
yeah I think it's probably good to see
people do stupid [ __ ] right you don't do
it right yeah and I got the scars to
prove it you know like there's their
shots of me getting bitten by sharks and
also I was like this is why you don't do
it he'd been bitten by shark just this
year I mean it's pretty minor but just
this year I took a single to eye
I'm a lemon shark while I was working in
the field with one dude let me see that
[ __ ] it's actually it's on my Instagram
page I think what's the scar below it oh
that's not a scar I burned myself
cooking crab last night on a pod I
should have only rolled this shirt down
here did I burn the top of my foot
cooking spaghetti yeah I was moving the
boat such a [ __ ] I was moving the boy
was cooking barefoot I was moving the
boiling water with the spaghetti in it
to the sink you know the put it in the
strainer and I spilled it on the top of
my oh wow and I had to keep my [ __ ]
together because I was holding the pot I
was like Chuck and I poured it in there
and then we were going to Hawaii
the next day No so while I was in Hawaii
I had to have like pointman over the top
my foot a bandage on it and I went into
the ocean with my my chucks on yeah they
were my converse all-stars in the ocean
I was like look I have to cover it like
I'll just do this and they'll just clean
it after I go in I'm like I'm not gonna
not go in the ocean man I'm [ __ ] you
know why I'm like if it gets infected
I'll I'll figure that out but how cool
did you look down in the ocean Chuck's
on I look at their loser yeah the next
day there was a they had some sort of an
issue with bacteria in the water where
they told people to get out of the water
great and she's got an open wound yeah
well what is never open fortunately it
just it just the skin over it like was
it was all totally red and then the skin
over it bubbled and then it eventually
after a while it healed and scratched up
now I just have a big giant red mark so
that's a bit yeah it was totally my
fault and I was being an idiot and we
were working off the back of the boat we
had all these lemon sharks around and we
were working to get tiger sharks and I
just dropped my guard for a second and
as I looked back to where my hand was in
the water I saw this shark coming like
that and I just pulled my arm back and I
literally just clipped a single tooth
but I think if it had been a fraction of
a second later that would have been the
hand [ __ ] how big was a shark that's
probably like it's um it's probably the
next page over it's probably an 8 foot
shark so it would've gone
me and I was lucky it just oh my god do
you could have lost your arm for sure oh
this is it this is a different it's a
tiger shark but it's pretty cool
nonetheless don't they have like Kevlar
that sharks can't bite through they do
they never wear that everywhere you go
that's a good question when you go to
the mall so I'd look about as cool as
you with your converse in the ocean well
you couldn't see the converse until I
got out of the oh that's Jared you can
you can see my Kevlar in the wall no
matter where you are no I don't know I
don't like anything that inhibits the
movement like that and does that stuff
inhibit the Kevlar stuff I've never worn
it
yeah those sharks behind and that's the
situation I was in I was on the back of
the boat like that apparently Catalina
like off Catalina there's a high shark
population yeah
white sharks and they're increasing
every year really mm-hmm why well
because we used to we used to hunt them
first of all and we used to hunt seals
and sea lions as well and that's all
been banned for a long time so there's
way more seals and sea lions now and
there's more sharks reproducing and I
think you know I think there's something
to be said for them the water being
consistently warmer and them staying
further north than they used to as well
or south depending on which way they're
but like where I live in Santa Barbara
there's a single Bay where my buddy and
I have been going for the last four
years and it's it's only for like three
four weeks
in the summertime that there's like six
to eight juvenile great white sharks
around and when we started going there
four years ago they were like six feet
long and then the next year they were
like eight feet long this year I I
didn't go because I was traveling but my
buddy went filmed them he's like dude
they're getting up to like 10 feet and
it's the same animals in the same spot
what happens when those are like 14 foot
animals it's a very popular swimming
Beach
oh yeah so who knows maybe they'll move
on maybe they would eat people maybe
they'd eat people well somebody got
eaten in Santa Barbara a few years back
right I believe there's a beach one I
don't know about Santa barb it happens
it's like once a year you know there's
some kind of attack a bite usually in
October do around lobster season or when
the swells start to pick up somebody
gets chomp so I sit around then I think
October I'd have to check on their
ecology I think it's right around when
they start breeding so they're they're
little
hold up but October is also when lobster
season starts so all the free divers are
free diving in and out of caves looking
like a seal the waves start to kick in
for the winter swells so you got more
people on surfboards it just seems like
the perfect cocktail of timing from for
miss ID that makes sense yeah that makes
sense it's uh it's such a beautiful
creature and it's so cool that they're
there but it's also you're like this
thing can kill people and it's right
there and and we go in the water yeah
and we swim around like yeah we have
we're so helpless out there completely
and you I think that's just the you just
have to know that going into it right
it's it's not like you're gonna you know
kiss your life goodbye every time you
get in the ocean but I mean you're
playing some audio yeah what is it from
that shark attack and said it's not this
was two years ago this guy caught it on
his GoPro attack remember oh my god dude
you're so slow in there yeah that's
what's oh Jesus
so is he prodding it get away from him
mm-hmm swimming backwards I think and
that's the right move you know give it a
poke keep it off you it bit his toe Wow
barely
that is a best-case scenario oh my god
the best-case yeah cool scar yeah take
your shoes off to show [ __ ] he kept his
little toe little toe just sliced by
there's such cool animals they deserve a
ton of respect you know and I think you
just have to realize they're they're
like yeah it's just a part of it there's
also a way to be smart about it right
don't go in there's bait balls and tons
of birds diving and tons of fish in the
water
you know stay out of the the immediate
surf zone and low-vis in a high sea
larrya you know there's ways to like
really reduce the risk we did new year's
in Hawaii last year and we got to see
some whales nice dude that is we were
real close yes so wild man they're so
big aren't they they're so big and so
beautiful it's like it's it's you're so
happy that they're there right you know
right and it's the the whale
one of those weird ones where you
looking at me like am i seeing this this
is really a whale in the water like
they're so magical yeah and so
intelligent that's amazing like they're
you know the general consensus is that
they're restricted by their morphology
like their body type doesn't allow them
to share with us how much more
intelligent they are than we really
realize but we know a little bit you
know we know how they can sing across
oceans and communicate and all get
together and yeah it's amazing
synchronizing the way they swim yeah
mazing creatures well and then there's
orcas who eat them yeah she's even more
[ __ ] up because we love orcas do you
see when you see an orca killing a whale
you like oh well that's where they got
their name right mm-hmm killer whale
yeah it's because they kill whales yep
and they are a whale they're in that
family yeah they're marine mammals they
killed dolphins too right yeah they're
they're dolphins whales fish stingrays
are seals sea lions sharks like they're
they're amazing predators yeah they
really are and it's like that polar bear
thing we're talking about earlier
they're like you know Shamu like cuddly
or stuffed toy they're smiling in every
cartoon but aren't they pretty cool too
people in general in the wild yeah
that's strange I believe there has never
been an attack on a human being by an
orca in the wild period there have been
multiple in aquariums you know well
there's been shows going on that kind of
stuff but I believe there's never
actually been a recorded case of a death
by Orca in the wild that's kind of crazy
when you think about it what just shows
their intelligence right it shows they
look at you and go nope that's not on
the menu like that's not that's not
something I need to eat they must be
hungry sometimes well what's interesting
about orcas is there's really two sexes
of their diet there's there's orcas that
only eat marine mammals and there's
orcas that only eat stingrays and some
other fish species and so I think you
know for those people you see some of
those incredible photographers like Paul
Nicola and stuff like that that get
those images of them underwater they're
diving with the fish eating orcas I
think a few people have been successful
in diving with the mammal eating ones
but that's I feel like that's a dice for
all our position mm-hmm they might miss
thank you well you you're a mammal and
you're not your seal sighs you know
Jamie who are we talking to about orcas
and the the population that lives in the
north the Pacific nor
West like around Seattle that only eats
the chinook salmon remember we were
having this conversation the other day
with somebody filled DeMars was it Phil
I mean I was a clip from probably yeah
okay so that's a crazy situation right
you have a population of orcas that only
eats chinook salmon and then there's a
decline in the population of chinook
salmon so they're trying to figure out
how to get them to eat seals right they
try in there like they won't do it right
there the local population but then they
have these migratory populations that
come in and do eat seals seals yeah and
they're like hey you [ __ ] are
starving to death [ __ ] food
everywhere right but they won't do it
they were I switch over it's very
strange isn't it and you got to wonder
how much of that is learned behavior
right how many parent orcas are passing
down this is the food you know this is
how you hunt salmon this is what you eat
right everything else is off the menu
versus what's instinctual like how did
that one group of orcas learn to eat
seals whereas the other one is so
dedicated to salmon it's it's amazing
well it's amazing that they didn't adapt
right they're starving granny don't
branch out right or maybe they're just
unsuccessful mmm you know maybe maybe
they've never learned how to hunt seals
because it's definitely a different
behavior to scooping up a fish right so
yeah it is amazing you'd think they
would get to this kind of tipping point
where they're like there's not enough to
eat we need to make a transition and
then are they unsuccessful in that
transition because they can't figure out
how to do it are they just not doing it
they just don't know about it it's who
knows it's a real bummer man when you
hear that they're almost starving to
death out there and they're trying to
actually bring chinook salmon to them
you know you know it's it's one of those
things it's like that whole kind of
micro environment is a game of Jenga
right you pull one piece out yeah I got
a tower still standing pull another
piece out and tower still standing you
know it just takes that one piece till
it all collapses that is an interesting
way of looking at it right you know they
were talking about Hawaii you know and
all these different invasive species
that live in Hawaii and there was this
discussion about pigs and they were
saying you know like we should really
take the pigs off of Hawaii and a lot of
the people in Hawaii like hang on right
we've been here as long as the pigs
right so like are we invasive right
what's invasive
now right when does it become because
obviously like luaus they're synonymous
with like eating pigs and wild pigs are
a big part of you know the people that
hunt in Hawaii this of their food source
yeah so they're like well would it but
then you have a situation like lanai
where I go every year the access tier
yeah which is terrible environmentally
it's a disaster right like it's it's all
wrong there are 30,000 deer on this one
island that many 30,000 they don't know
really they're dead guessing this the
estimates between twenty and thirty
thousand right and there's three
thousand people yeah ensued you ain't
never seen anything like it because it's
a little ass island around the whole
thing in an hour
uh-huh I mean maybe a little bit more
than that but not much sure it's a tiny
[ __ ] island right and there's so many
deer yeah that's you'll see them on like
you'll you get your binoculars out and
you look at this huge field and you're
like oh my god don't you see a thousand
oh you're kidding no wow it's great it's
so unnatural no predators only humans
plenty of food right right and they're
just populations exploded everywhere
yeah and they're damn delicious people
who live there it's amazing you know
like if you don't have to have much
money to eat really well right you get a
rifle you go out there bang you got a
deer and you could shoot as many as you
want right you choose seven in a day and
stockpile your freezer and have all your
meat for the year and they're that
abundant like if someone stock yeah
the only thing that keeps me from
killing a ton of them is that I use a
bow and arrow it's really hard to do
with the bow and arrow because they're
so fast and they evolved in Asia to get
away from Tigers mhm
they're an Indian animal right right oh
it's super fast it's it's a tough
argument that could because you're right
like Hawaiian people Pig is culturally
significant to them you know just like
probably access to yours to the people
of lanai and has been for however long
the deer have been there but I guess
it's like at what cost
right at what cost if and I don't think
this is the case but if someone said
look if I know these pigs are culturally
significant to you but if we leave them
here the whole islands ecosystem will
collapse there'll be no birds no fish
you know no lizards nothing is it worth
it to have pigs right like that's and
it's delicate the pigs in particular
wreck is eat everything the
nesting birds still devastate everything
everything of a roots [ __ ] up every tree
everything that's coming up all the
sprouts and everything yeah they're
super destructive here there's
destructive here in California yeah it's
not it's not isolated to Hawaii
everywhere that we've brought pigs
they've done a lot of we're actually
gonna I was we're talking about this out
here we're gonna film something about
hunting pigs at Tejon ranch because to
hone rant the place gets devastated
their agriculture gets devastated by
these pigs there's so many of them right
and they're all over Northern California
has problem in San Jose they're in
people's yards they're destroying
[ __ ] because they're the if you
don't kill them they just breed and
breed and breed and breed and breed and
breed and then they just expand right
and they're they're dealing with them
now even in the northern part of the
United States dealing with them in the
Northeast there was a New York Times
article about it so you can find that
from two days ago about the expansion of
wild pigs is that they're starting to
make their way into the northeastern
states and they're just they can't be
stopped they can survive in any weather
yep they breathe three times a year they
can they're viable I think from the time
they're 5 to 6 months old they have
their first litter feral pigs roamed the
south now even in northern states aren't
safe the swine have established
themselves in Canada when approaching on
border states like Montana and North
Dakota [ __ ] man if they get into Montana
they'll do so much damage you know
what's crazy about the feral pigs in the
United States they were brought here by
I believe Christopher Columbus starting
with six animals so the entire 200
million or whatever it is across the
u.s. I don't know the number it was like
six or eight or ten original pigs that
were brought in by Christopher Columbus
and dropped in Florida that's insane
guns you want to talk about how crazy
they can reproduce and how much damage
they do like think of the biomass of
those animals stemming off of like six
of them that's insane and they're so
tough you can put them on a boat and
they'll make it across the ocean oh yeah
no there are may and and they are
terrible for the environment like they
do so much damage to native species to
riparian habitats I mean they're I like
you said we were talking about it out
there briefly and it's it's a good thing
people should realize that invasive
species like that should not be in an
ecosystem well
they certainly shouldn't be in an
ecosystem when there's no balance right
if they're warthogs and they're in
Africa there's a system for that exactly
but they're all they're supposed to be
the warthogs are wild looking you've
seen one up there I grew up in Zimbabwe
oh that's right yeah I actually got a
pretty funny story about a warthog my
uncle my mom's brother we were out on
Safari one time and he was he was young
you know he's much much younger than my
mother so he's maybe a teenager or
something and he grabbed this plum and
started going for a walk across camp and
anyway this warthog decided it wanted
this plum and so it came trotting after
my uncle and started chasing him in
circles around this tree but my uncle
was so panicked by this thing chasing
him around this big bay of AB tree that
he wouldn't drop the plum so he's just
in this perpetual cycle of being chased
around this tree until he eventually
threw the plum and the warthog just
veered off and went for the plum lucky
did one him yeah they're very funny very
mischievous I love the way their tails
stick up through the grass when they're
running around they're weird-looking
very they're there they're related to
pigs right some sort of way yeah oh yeah
yeah they're all that same family
speaking of weird pigs are you familiar
with the Barbarossa no this is one we
should pull out you're gonna love this
animal yeah you're gonna love this it's
one of my top bucket list animals to see
in the wild it's a great name yeah
Barbarossa
you got I don't want to tell you what it
is till you see the answers you're gonna
be like no way that's real it looks like
something out of Star Wars really mm-hmm
and it's pig where does it live
Indonesia
how BIG's you get uh maybe 200 pounds
I'm not positive on the sighs wow look
at that thing look at those tusks what
growing out that's good those things
that grow out of it's the middle of its
head yep that's crazy yeah look at that
one what the bro that does not look real
right does that look like something out
of Star Wars yes that's a real animal
that looks like an avatar creature
that's that looks like is that fighting
something looks like it fighting there
oh my god well Bruce is going to war if
it's a big deer they call it a pig do
you know this is Barbarossa or a pig
deer just might be somebody just let's
guess like their nickname of it I think
they're
Oh getting it all that's not [ __ ]
more that's just shitty Barbarossa
jujitsu yeah that's the kind of fighting
mommy and daddy do late at night
mommy and daddy were just playing don't
worry no one's getting hurt mommy was
gagging yeah well who are you cursor is
click on that one
what the [ __ ] man isn't that a wild pig
the things coming out of it the tusks
that come out of the middle of its head
are so strange like where did that come
from
I I don't know why you evolved that
maybe it may be like a peacocks tail you
know for a showmanship but what's really
crazy about them evolving those two two
teeth their tusks out of their their
bridge their snout is they if they're
not broken in fights and rooting around
they can grow long enough that they will
puncture the animal in the head and kill
it I've heard of that oh that's why cuz
I put an image of it on my my Instagram
it was one of those Jeffrey Epstein
didn't kill himself memes oh yeah Sophia
does he threw up and it was a Barbarossa
skull actually oh saying that it would
can do that actually was driving into
its own head growing into its own head
yeah like that yeah
insane that's crazy like maybe that's
nature's way of saying all right enough
yeah check please
yeah live forever everything in front of
you like that one look at that yeah okay
there it is growing into its own brain
imagine what a like one day you have
like a little bit of a headache and the
next day just gets a little worse like
what is going on and what do you do it's
like if you go and you know get down
against the ground it's only gonna get
worse right it's already in your brain
yeah yeah you'd have to get it you'd
have to be smart enough to find a branch
we could slip that over and torque your
head yeah I don't think I don't think it
off I don't think that's happening if
you're a pig is this awful I mean often
that this happens where they kill
themselves by growing that tusks into
their brain I don't know that looks like
two of them heading that direction bark
a crazy animal what a beautiful animal
so there's an extinct subspecies of
those called the maloca and Barbarosa
which in the single island near Sulawesi
they used to be and then they think
people have hunted him you know to
extinction localized extinction within
that island and that subspecies but some
people I know that
worked over there 8:1 so they're like
yeah no we ate this wild pig with these
crazy horns really I was like yeah this
is like two years ago you know and they
have no proof and they don't have the
skull and they don't have the picture
they were like they were traveling and
they're like yeah we got back and we ate
this pig with these wild horns on this
particular island and I was like wait is
that possibly a Moluccan Barbarossa I
was like I don't know and you look where
they were and what they said and what
they ate and it's like oh that could be
an extinct and extinct subspecies that
you guys consume well how many
biologists are actually actively out
there looking for these creatures
well those I would say zero currently
that species but with regards to this
field of presumed extinct animals it
seems to be a movement that's expanding
you know and I think one of the reasons
for that is we have a rate of something
like 2,000 species a year being deemed
extinct right so when you have that many
animals being deemed extinct every year
there's there's Flags being put up is it
really extinct have we looked everywhere
and so this you know I don't want to say
I was the first but I feel like I was in
that wave of first people to start
looking into extinction as far as an
ongoing animals wrongfully deemed
extinct and now it's like it's like
mainstream in the biology world
it's like there's a lot of people that
are like I'm gonna go see if I can find
this thing is it because it's a romantic
sort of thing there's a lot of cash like
if you can find an a seem to be extinct
Barbarosa I think so I think it's very
romantic yeah you know as opposed to
just setting out to study something that
we know that's there this like harrowing
journey to find this creature that the
world is written off it's very romantic
you have you ever heard of the are wrong
pen deck what is it this is like this is
a cryptid right yes
what is this funny monkey person that's
right did we talk about this last time
we might have yeah I'm very repetitive
that's okay I don't like it it's still
fun it's not in my wheelhouse
you know like the cryptids the lock
thing I think is in Vietnam I think it's
in Vietnam and maybe some other parts of
Southeast Asia and the the the most
people thought it was nonsense
until the homo Florrie ANSYS until they
found out about that Hobbit person that
lives in the island of Flores and then
they're like okay hold on or lived right
so right as recently as 14,000 years ago
right so when they found out about
that thing like well me maybe these
little [ __ ] are still hanging around
out there somewhere
yeah just you're dealing with incredibly
dense jungle and they're very wary if
you're a person stomping through the
jungle something that lives there hears
you a mile away for sure yeah you're not
sneaking up on donkey no well we this
year I went into song dune which is the
world's largest cave that was only
discovered in 1995 it's this massive
opening six miles of underground cave
you know you don't see daylight for two
days six miles it's you should look at
the pictures of this place you'll love
it I mean it's just this me it looks
like something out of a vut R I mean
this cave you can fit New York City
skyscrapers inside of it it's so big it
has its own weather system what yeah
it's it's where is this song and so it's
in the Anna might mountain range between
Vietnam and Laos and we got to go into
it this year because we were looking for
this habitat in fact this is my show
that comes out tonight we were looking
for this habitat ours it on so people
can hear Extender live tonight at 9 p.m.
on Animal Planet we go into song dune
cave say your dvrs kids plug but let's
see this oh my god yeah there there's
you know hang song doing that's the
entrance to it and like look at the size
of it the scope of it is compare it to
what am I looking at I'm seeing the
little tents
oh those are tents there's full lake
systems in there and my god that's
inside the tent I mean that's inside the
key yeah look at the wedding cake that
one right there
that's called the wedding cake it's yeah
that one it's these pyres I mean it's
just it's the most fantastic looking
thing there's a person standing on top
of that little pyre right there oh my
god yeah that's insane it's insane
more people have summited Everest than
have been through that cave Wow well
people summit Evers every day now Wow
that's why but yeah so we that's the
wedding hang my god that's incredible
picture just like that that I'm very
proud of god that's so spectacular but
what's amazing is about two-thirds of
the way through the system you can see
where what you're looking at is areas
where the cave roof has collapsed and
there's isolated pockets of ecosystem
right so we were talking about the the
pygmy people that could live in the
of Vietnam this is the kind of my point
is this giant six mile-long cave with
these huge openings wasn't even
discovered until I think 95 so what's to
say a tribe of small people couldn't
hide in something like that and move in
and out and never be seen I mean it's
it's fantastic
there was a stupid movie about people
that lived underground that ate people
remember that this is Becca chicks was
that duck cave team watched we spent
like we were going like leading up to
this expedition we're like all right
let's lucky a bunch of bad our cave
movies before we go the first ones bad
the second one is so bad it's it's funny
yeah they did a descent to bringing that
up I stumbled across a video potential
it's obviously probably not real of an
orang pendeks no it's totally real Jamie
I know but have you ever seen this these
guys are on my dick and this thing
Strunz out in front of them it doesn't
look like CGI is the only thing I'm
going with at the moment
it's obviously probably that's
definitely a person it had a tail or
some points it would do like freeze
frames of it what I stopped watching
because you guys took me on the cave
thing but huh it's a ten minute video I
just side if you neither of you have
seen this before that I've ever seen we
are doing a new there in Vietnam I think
so row if they were just out riding
their bikes and this thing they caught
it on their GoPros and they're trying to
find it let's see they could also be
trying to troll everyone internet I
don't know these guys have a troll video
I mean what is their their YouTube page
we got any two pages it's on uh it's
like on a Bigfoot
Webster Sasquatch complices but that's
the problem is it remember in men in
black how they used to always check the
whatever it was called a check like the
National Enquirer for like tips on
aliens yeah because where else do you go
to get this info alright you see this
again I'm not right right here that's
definitely a person or a humanoid it's
really tiny whatever it is yeah it's
running pretty fast
yeah it also could be like [ __ ] yeah
yeah could be [ __ ] but it could be a
little monkey person like me we know
those little monkey people were real
yeah exactly
goddamn imagine if that's real and keep
in mind and again I'm not like a huge
cryptid guy but keep in mind you know as
a homo sapien they have a higher
intellect which means they're better at
avoiding people right so it's you know
it's it's not unreasonable to say if
there was a group of small humanoids out
there that didn't want to be discovered
they could stay hidden yeah and if it's
really small you know and and also some
sort of a hominid that has intelligence
right it's probably got a pretty decent
food source in the jungle yep but they
would find a dead one wouldn't they
that's always the argument right why
isn't there a roadkill yes or why yeah
but the thing is like there's a lot of
mountain lions good luck finding a dead
one yeah yeah there's that look at that
yeah that's like the best screenshot I
don't think that's a tail that looks
like a spear yeah yeah I mean who knows
who's what's to say that isn't a short
guy who's been poaching and he's like
crap I'm getting busted Yeah right
but doesn't mean it's not fascinating
and this is the kind of stuff that we
wade through in droves to try and figure
out you know are these animals are these
creatures still out there
that's so weird god I'm such a sucker
though oh that thing looks like it's
wearing shorts dude doesn't it yeah yeah
I know and it's running exactly like a
person that's a little froze but it's so
little
right kid that's the thing about though
it could be a little kid yeah but that's
the thing about the orang pendeks
is that they think it was like the homo
florensis I think they think it's really
the same thing in the homo Fleur ANSYS
was really a three foot tall human [ __ ]
feet yeah right some yeah some subset
yep there's another image good oh wow
yeah that looks like a little person
that looks weird though it's got a hat
yeah it's wearing a hat we're we're in a
Disneyland about the ears because it
matches the roaring pendick images of
that Sasquatch type head or something
dude that is a person with a stick and
there and there that creature looks
naked it doesn't look like they're
shorts on yeah it does so how tall do
you think that is
that looks really short and moving fast
I mean short in like three feet tall
girl going into tall grass right what's
that 3-foot grass 4-foot grass that's so
okay so here's size comparison see I'm
such a sucker look a lookout look
there's a size comparison that is
[ __ ] tiny miss tiny it's really tiny
oh my god it's real such a moral it's
such a [ __ ] when it comes to stuff I
believe in Bigfoot for so long between
80 and 150 centimeters which is
somewhere between 30 and 60 inches tall
that's amazing I hope it's real yeah I
do too I need to yeah I mean it's
fantastic do you hope would you rather
not knowing and it lives or someone
kills it and you find out that it's real
I'd rather not knowing and it lives meat
for sure yeah me too but I feel like a
[ __ ] right right you know what come on
man just tell me and how blurry does the
line get in that situation because it's
it's humanoid right so it's like right
it's not like you're catching them
putting them in zoos you know what to
breed them and keep the population up
like like that gets really dicey super
dicey yeah and they do that with an
African man in the Bronx Zoo and like
the turn of the century they put an
African man in the Bronx yes they did
yeah they have an African man I believe
it was the Bronx Zoo in like the 1800s
or the early 1900s you know paid me yep
bottom bingo what year was it 1906 oh
wow yeah it's they had them in the zoom
it's insane
look at that Wow dudes in the zoo yeah
well you know what man people were just
figuring life out back then right right
this is the reality of human beings is
that we have not been alive that
and we have not been civilized in terms
of how we view the world today with
inclusivity and objectivity and care and
you know kindness towards others like
this compassion and altruism this is on
a global scale this is fairly recent
yeah we're figuring things out there we
go I mean the history is a perfect it
can show you how we progressed yeah it's
a document documentation of how we
progress but yet still that 150 years
after slavery yeah right that's crazy
yeah 40 45 years after slavery what the
[ __ ] guys
so Bronx Zoo you know speaking in our
like weird cryptid realm reminded me of
something so get this
Chewbacca bruh has been attributed to
the possibility that there are thylacine
in North America and here's what
supports that there is documented proof
that however many years ago I don't
remember the dates there were two
breeding pair of thylacine bound for the
Bronx Zoo and they boat crashed into the
shore and most of the animals escaped
including the two breeding pair of
thylacine fast forward 10 15 years you
start having these Chupacabra sightings
pop up in the Northeast and these
animals were adapted to living in
Tasmania which is a pretty similar
climate to the North America and North
East and so there's people that have
kind of drawn these parallels and said
oh the chupacabra that we've reported
running around you know the United
States is actually a tiny remnant
population of these thylacine that were
brought here for the Bronx Zoo that
escaped what you buying this no not
specially though right but it sounds
it's an amazing story he had me if you
said yes stuff you talked about if
someone could get one for the Bronx Zoo
then what a rich person have been able
to buy one like a rich guy in Texas for
instance a thylacine been able to
purchase one privately yeah you can
probably get one today
what I'll see ya go to Bubba's house but
especially back then there were no like
import-export laws about wildlife you
know you could just bring in whatever
you liked if you had money you know
what's to say that everybody was in a
race to collect stuff for zoos and
museums like what's to say somebody
didn't bring some in Texas and there
exotics it's so strange I mean I had a
bit about it in my act in 2016 my
Netflix special that there's more tigers
in captivity in Texas and private
collections then there are and all of
the wild of the world isn't that insane
just Texas and that's like in guys
living rooms in you know a cage yeah
yeah a mistake yeah it is not their
rules they're so strange it's also
that's one of the rare states where the
vast majority of the state is private
land
oh really very little public land in
Texas so like for yourself and you go
hunting there it's all private yes
you're gonna hunt in Texas you're gonna
hunt most likely on a private ranch
there's some small patches of public
land but in comparison I think more than
I think it's in the 90% range interest
yeah that that's it's all giant ranches
right and what's really interesting is I
I've been reading a lot about over the
last two to three months I've been
obsessed with Wild West stories from put
that bug away Empire the summer moon SC
Guin wrote this fantastic book about the
Comanches okay and they're the the
battle with people in Texas and the
Texas Rangers in the 1800s and trying to
trying to take over that land from the
Comanches it's crazy yeah this stuff
happened just you know 150 years ago
right it was so insane and really sad
really sad because there's something
incredibly romantic about their
lifestyle
there was just 150 years ago when all of
Europe they were you know having horse
driven carriages and people were living
in these fancy buildings but right here
in North America people were living like
they were in the Stone Age right and
they had this incredible nomadic nomadic
life where they were following around
the Buffalo and killing the Buffalo and
they
they they were all just about war there
was this wild ferocious tribe that was
about war and hunting buffalos some it's
[ __ ] amazing man
and that's like well our
great-grandparents walking the earth yes
really recent you know I mean they they
kind of they they put the kibosh on it
all by the time it was like 1870s in
that range that's when they they
eventually moved them all into
reservations but he [ __ ] and not the
Comanches the Comanches they never moved
into reservation right right they just
gave them plots of land they'd to this
day don't have a reservation but and bad
land is my understand terrible [ __ ]
yeah yeah but they were [ __ ] to each
other too right that's what's really
[ __ ] up like he you get this idea that
like the natives all lived in peace and
harmony and the you know you know the
Europeans came over and they [ __ ]
everything up right they were killing
each other left and right right they
were the tribes would raid on other
tribes and they would I mean horrific
things and this guy goes into amazing
detail about the way they would torture
both captives from other tribes and
Europeans and anybody that was over they
cut their legs off their cut their arms
I'll throw them on the fire watching
wiggle around while they were still
alive like wild [ __ ] man and he said
that even left some of it out that it
was so distasteful really yeah he was
trying to figure out like how he could
put it in a book and literally not have
people vomit unbelievable yeah so it's
[ __ ] amazing no but that's this whole
country this whole continent used to be
this wild ecosystem of human beings
riding horses chasing Buffalo all these
animals all over the place I mean during
the the hundred and fifty plus years or
250 plus years they eradicated so many
animals they have extra pay to them from
so many different parts of the country
and then market hunting came in and they
just just almost wiped out like so many
different species of North American
animals and not just almost but did you
know like pre human settlement they say
that the North American continent had
more biomass like larger game and more
abundant megafauna than the plains of
Africa now huge animals are ain't
roaming around and and you know European
settlement
and Native American settlement it's all
it's all attributed to the decline but
things like more recently like the
passenger pigeon yeah right billions
billions billions it would black out
this guy yeah and down to zero how the
[ __ ] did they do that I honestly like I
know by reading but I personally don't
know you know what I mean how do you
feel billions of birds yeah and that
gets intricate because the animals
ecology is such that it needs many
others you know their their tactic is
confusion like they don't they don't run
away they just get in a big giant flock
and then you're like oh I don't know
which one to pick but so that it made
him easier to hunt and there was
commercial they'd actually hunt them
commercially for meat it was cheap meat
ba-ba-ba-ba but it just it's crazy to
think that we're able to wipe out
billions of anything in such a short
amount of time well we came real close
to doing to the buffalo yeah and some of
those well the bison I should say some
of those images of those bison skulls
like stack tiles yeah like a mountain
it's really disturbing it used to be you
know considered entertainment to shoot
them from the railway as you were
traveling across the country for fun
once kind of hang out the window man
boom got one well the other thing is
that they would go and they mostly what
they would take from them as their
tongues which is crazy it's the best
meat in the world and they wouldn't even
eat the meat right they would shoot them
and take their tongues and they would
pickle their tongues right and they
would use the fur they would you know
sell the hides and make buffalo capes
all this different [ __ ] it just shows
what abundance we had you know I mean
nowadays not that I'm Pro wiping out
anything but nowadays you have a small
population of whatever this the animal
is and most people are utilizing every
part of it right because we don't have
that crazy abundance like imagine if you
just went out like like you for instance
imagine if you just went out to shoot
out for the tongue it doesn't make any
sense right like why on earth would you
ever consider doing that but if if you
looked out of the studio here and you
saw two hundred of them you'd be like
yeah right I might grab a tongue today
right that's the difference hawk oh yeah
it's the difference of the abundance
yeah well they were basically two elk
right a bison is like twice as hard yeah
yeah they're enormous so ridiculous that
they just cut the tongue out it's awful
yes yeah and it's also
crazy because it's such a it's such an
iconic symbol of the American West my
friend Steve Rinella wrote a great book
it's called American Buffalo and he
actually did the audio version of it too
and he's a really good narrator it's
it's excellent book but it's all about
the history of the Plains tribes then
North American Buffalo and sorry what'd
you say it's calling her called American
Buffalo American Buffalo they get the
audio version if you're into audiobooks
yes he reads it he does an amazing job
and it's his book and he actually had
sold it and then someone else had got
the rights you know that whatever the
book company had decided to have an
actor read it okay and is terrible Steve
yeah yeah he was like it was terrible
and then 10 years later the rights he
got the rights back and then he was able
to oh great with himself it's awesome
yeah I fly so much audiobooks for my
best man I love them I've been I haven't
listened to podcasts in months in like
the last two months have been mostly
listening to audiobooks I mean I have a
little bit but yeah mostly just
audiobooks yeah you ever done the power
of one oh yeah I've read that was a
couple of years ago yeah my favorites
yeah it's great audio book - who's read
it who's the author of that again I
don't recall I think he's kind of a
one-hit wonder with that book I can't
remember his name but love absolutely
love the story pull that up Jamie see
what's up a movie they made a movie
probably like some kung fu movie yeah
Bryce Court that's right Bryce Court can
you pull up the image of the book what's
the description of the book what does it
say
is that it the power of one is a novel
expense no I don't think that's it
no that's definitely not it no no it's
the Bryce Courtenay one for sure it is
about it's about a young boy growing up
in Africa so there's a novel
yeah I've okay I read it first and then
I then I listened to the alright I'm
confused so I know I have not read this
okay it's very good there's a there's
something that has a similar title
that's like a self-help book oh no this
is not a self-help book this is this is
about a young boy growing up in Africa
during apartheid he's very like
ostracized from his peers because he's
not I believe I'd have to listen to it
again because he's not you know Bora
he's not a Dutch African he's English
African and it's just it's his journey
through life basically and it's really
good yeah but it
what reminded me of it is we were
talking about all the wildlife and he
grows up very much so in the bush in
Africa and around wildlife and you know
he's juggling that and a kind of defunct
social system and it's it's really good
Africa is so special it's such as
whenever I watch documentaries on Africa
and African wildlife is like what a
crazy place yeah
where all the nutty things live pretty
much and a lot of them too that's what's
great you know we have some nutty things
here we have mountain lions and
Grizzlies and stuff like that but it
ain't [ __ ] compared to what they have in
Africa there's no you know having walked
kind of through the wilds basic in a lot
of different places there's no where
I've been like Africa where you're so
like okay I'm just a part of the food
system now like I'm not at the top
anymore like I'm in the food web you
know lions can be hunting me elephants
can charge
there's leopards in the trees you know I
mean you're just like you just fit into
the food web you're not at the top of it
any longer yeah it's such a weird place
to when it comes to wildlife when you
know they brought so many animals back
from the brink of extinction
only because they have value for hunting
right so it's so told you everyone's so
torn on that because it's on one hand
like you would you would love it if
people had donated enough money to keep
these animals healthy and keep them in
good populations because we appreciate
right but that's not really the case
it's mostly people that want to shoot
them that are paying money and because
they have value now the populations are
so large yeah and so everyone's like
really torn on that like oh this is
weird
and it's even hunters are torn on for
sure and it's a full spectrum sorry I
don't mean in here no it's okay because
they're all fenced in I was right right
it's not like when you think of hunting
you think of I'm going to go to the wild
right and I'm gonna experience these
animals but know these animals like
they're making sure there's a large
population of them because Mike from
Cleveland is coming over there with his
Creedmoor and he's gonna you know shoot
something yeah and it's such a spectrum
is what I was going to say because you
have these national parks that
absolutely do work people pay enough
money for tourism ecotourism dollars to
do photo safaris and the Wildlife's
manage you have these other areas that
are managed by hunting dollars and
they're managed to flee well they're
sustaining animals there they're
reproducing them and they're they're
putting them in other habitats and
ecosystems and parts of Africa and then
you have ones that are supposed to be
managed properly both from ecotourism
and hunting dollars and they're just
they're funding people's pockets the
animals are getting devastated it's
super unethical and it's and everything
in between and that's the problem with
Africa is like you know I'm all for
hunting as a tool for conservation if it
keeps the species around and keeps the
animals up but you got to be careful
where you're going where those dollars
are going because it's so easy to line
someone's pocket and it never returns to
the species yeah there's a giant issue
with corruption they're huge huge yeah I
mean ever you have poverty right yeah
where I grew up in Zimbabwe the Mugabe
regime I mean it's it's notorious for
being as corrupt as it was and you know
created violence and uprisings and
that's why my family came here cuz we
got thrown off our land and like crazy
stuff it's it's very very corrupt yeah
it's it's a wild place man yeah my buddy
Justin Bren runs this charity do you
know who he is
I don't runs fight for the Forgotten
they build wells for the pygmies okay we
work with them with the cash app and he
came back with a terrible disease I
heard that on your podcast yeah doesn't
know what it is they don't know what it
is he's got some crazy parasites they
think it might be in his brain oh boy
not only that he goes so deep into the
Congo that they feel like it might be
an undiscovered parasite yeah like he
might be the first one this shouldn't
laugh it's like that's the worst way to
find a new species ever yeah it's been
going on for six months and he's like in
really poor health he's all [ __ ] up
yeah and he's a fighter for Bellator
he's one of their top heavyweights yeah
and so you know he's in the prime of his
career and he can't really work out
right oh he'll work out then I'll break
out into cold sweats and they have to
get him in the shower and and you know
heat his body up like it's it's a mess
it's really bad and the you know the
drugs that they put them on the other
thing is when you're on antibiotics one
of the side effect of some antibiotics
like cipro is that your ligaments get
weak oh yeah and so he's a [ __ ] cage
fighter right right so I'm carrying his
shoulders like both of the shoulders are
[ __ ] up now because your your
connective tissue is just not as strong
because of the you know our whole system
apparently I mean I really don't know
what I'm talking about but apparently
our whole system is fueled sort of it's
it's one gigantic unit and so when you
do something like you introduce
antibiotics and you crush all these
invading diseases or these invading
bacteria or whatever the [ __ ] staph or
whatever whatever is [ __ ] it the
microorganisms yeah all the microbiome
the rest of your body gets devastated as
well sure including like people who are
prone more prone to depression
afterwards and dr. Rhonda Patrick was
talking about that she had a staph
infection and it screwed her up for a
long time really just because her whole
body was out of whack from the
antibiotics because you know you get
staff they're worried about you're gonna
die oh yeah so they just pump you full
of anything that tries to kill of course
it Marla's story no no good deed goes
unpunished
don't try help people he's got malaria
three times - oh geez yeah yeah but I
bet he's passionate about what he does
and you know he's made he's made an
impact so the most passionate yeah he's
like the most generous person I've ever
met my life and every time I talk to him
I feel like a selfish piece of [ __ ] he's
dedicating his whole life and everything
for other people everything is for the
Congo everything is for the pygmies it's
amazing it's [ __ ] amazing
it is it really is very admirable
however he's [ __ ] yeah like you said
like they don't know what end they think
it might be in his brain well which is a
giant issue over hoarsely yeah she's
mean and obviously if it's in his brain
I mean depending upon what kind of
parasite it is it could be growing it's
just I hate parasites it's like the one
thing that makes my skin crawl that's
weird cuz I love them yeah parasites
I mean birds are cool but not a
professor like that in college actually
really yeah it's parasitologist he loved
him
well he's obsessed field of study yeah
yeah yeah so the last time I saw you I
think was right before we headed to the
Galapagos I was telling you about that
crazy Island we went on we found that
tortoise do you know that Lee yeah first
only one specimen has ever been found
before 114 years ago and we found the
second one we the the biggest discovery
my entire career was the week after I
saw you last Wow yeah it was amazing
what kind of tortoise is this a
Fernandina island tortoise big galapagos
tortoise on this crazy active volcano on
far remote galapagos we had gnarly
sunstroke heatstroke i mean everything
and after a few days of hiking up and
down this volcano we found scat and we
found a dig like a tortoise had been
digging and 15 minutes later we found
the animal well I mean how many of them
are in the wild there's a return trip
that just one more turn trip just went
right now and then another one will go
in January but what's great is on the
first return trip they had to bail
because of weather and the weather is
very harsh there they found evidence of
two more animals so things are looking
really good so there might be like four
alive on the planet Wow right now
there's one the one we found she's
literally the rarest animal in the world
let me do you have an image of this
there's it's on my Instagram but it was
on Forbes Times New York you know
everywhere it was like big big stuff so
you can look up for an Indian island
tour when you find something like that
what gets done to ensure the the
population remember she is Wow how did
you know what's the distinguishing
factors like what what's the only animal
on the island is the only tortoise on
the island so because you know tortoises
can't swim
at least not across the ocean well so
because of because of where they were if
we had found a tortoise it was going to
be the Fernandina tortoise now that
being said the unique shell ridging the
shape actually there's yeah it's a video
yeah there you go there she is so cool
there's a video oh I think it's the one
in the top right of your screen right
now
I never carried it away yeah we put her
in she was super malnourished
underweight dehydrated she was stuck in
an isolated pocket of Education because
there's nothing but lava around her now
this video is boring but there's there's
a cool one where you actually see me
like find her in the bushes and yeah it
was baby I was pretty happy just such a
big find and such you know the tortoise
like lonesome George the icon of
conservation so to find the species that
the world had lost for 114 years was
pretty pretty great actually being a
tortoise just chilling on this [ __ ]
Island hanging out some famous biologist
flies from all the way around the world
to find you trying to find some plants
bro but I think in this case she was
stoked and I'll tell you why she was
super dehydrated super underweight
it's terrible living conditions and she
was stuck right so it's not like she
could roam around the island and find
lots of food and water and there's five
foot shards of lava rock surrounding
this little pocket of vegetation so we
moved her to the fossil Lorena breeding
facility which is where lonesome George
was kept
then how their famous tortoise she put
on like seven pounds or 17 pounds in
like three weeks cuz she was so happy to
eat she didn't leave her water dish for
like ten days because she was just so
happy to see water like oh wow he was
stoked and now they're now they're
trying to find a male and trying to some
freak oh yeah trying to get the freaking
thing and they're this is this is
spurred like a ton of you know resources
conservation dollars returned efforts
like it's just it's really big for the
Galapagos so how does that work if you
do find a male if you do find what if
she's an old lady she doesn't wanna [ __ ]
and you bring some mail and he's like
hey baby and he's like 15 and she's 80
that's just like come on dude
fortunately rainfall water yeah
fortunately reptiles breed until they
die so so we should be good and and even
more interesting than that is tortoises
can retain viable sperm so what we had
hoped when we found her was that you
know maybe she'd copulated with a male
10 years prior and had been under such
tough environmental stress that she
hadn't had the the biological energy to
lay eggs and we're thinking oh let's get
her some food get her some water who
knows maybe she'll give some offspring
so she might already have fertilized
eggs inside of her from 10 years ago
yeah they can confirm can live in them
too like up to 20 years
that's some serious berm yeah serious
what god damn what [ __ ] what
longevity yeah amazing really yeah so if
they find a viable male and then they
bring him to the facility and introduce
him to all the food and water do they
have success in taking these wild
tortoise tortoises and getting them to
breed absolutely any you know I think
when you hear this yeah and I think when
you hear this you're thinking they're
like in a box you know what I mean in
the zoo they're in this thing that's
bigger than your studio here I don't
mean this room the whole studio you know
I mean it's all natural vegetation
basically we just moved her from one
island to another where there's less
stress and now if they get a male
they'll just have them together
hopefully they'll be offspring then they
can release the offspring back on the
island the population can remain stable
that's awesome
Wow so that was cool that was fun but I
remember I was sitting here and we were
talking about so yeah you know tomorrow
I leave for the Galapagos it's gonna be
gnarly it's gonna suck and then we had
this amazing fine so it was really cool
now that the Galapagos is so protected
that don't they make you like put fresh
shoes on like you can't bring shoes that
you war somewhere else that might carry
seeds yep we had to go to quarantine for
48 hours everything we brought with us
had to go into a giant freezer
yeah freezer and sit there for two days
and we kind of had to twiddle our thumbs
just waiting and then we got all our
stuff back got on the boats and went out
to that Isle so the giant freezer
supposedly kills any sort of spores or
you know it gets really cold if I
remember correctly and they go you know
you go through everything they look I go
through your boots you look for any
seeds you go through your underwear like
literally everything to see if you're
bringing any contaminants in god that's
so [ __ ] cool it is so the Galapagos
is really the
place where Darwin started formulating a
lot of his theories of evolution right
with the finches and the tortoises yeah
that they're crazy skeleton what is that
from some kind of marine mammal sea lion
possibly whale it's hard to say
they got beach there or something hmm
Wow and then that's Fernandina that's
the stark island in the background
actually where we found the tortoise oh
wow yeah
it's a big-ass island man it's behind
one turtle notice it's all good I have a
hard time with that get lazy and just
call most Turtles - Oh [ __ ] the
problem yeah
just swim better ya know so that was
cool it was crazy it was very difficult
and hot and you know all those things
and just so exciting that's amazing yeah
that was fun so when you do have a
discovery like this I mean that that's
got to like open up the door for more
funding more research possibilities more
trips hugely what do you want to do next
well it's so there's that's twofold
right one is it doesn't necessarily open
the door for me more which is good it
doesn't need to it opens the door for
the species and what I mean by that is
when it animals declared extinct that's
it it's gone right extinct means
vanished like no longer in existence so
when you find it back that that opens up
the dollars for a return efforts
management blah blah blah and that's
what's going on currently for that
particular species it's great for me in
the sense that it's like oh this guy is
furthering his reputation of being able
to find these things that other people
aren't which really just boils down to
me being willing willing to embrace
shittier conditions and a lot of other
people are but what's next for me I mean
I I take off for Africa I think January
4th January 5th and I'll be there for
five weeks working on some some missing
sharks missing sharks yeah what kind of
sharks there's four species that in the
wild coast which is like from Durban up
to Mozambique on the east of
southeastern Africa that haven't been
seen in 30 years or more and it's not
necessarily that they're extinct so much
as nobody looks for them and you know
it's like that's a very gray area of are
these animals still there or not and so
myself this guy named Dave Ebert he's
the president of the North American
elastomer brands Society like big shark
guy you know
big other bionerd like myself we're
teaming up and we're going down there
too to try and find some of these
animals I was reading something recently
about great whites in South Africa that
there's a massive decline mm-hmm orcas
orcas were killing white sharks in in
muscle bay that area where Hans Bahia
and I don't exactly remember the reason
I think they were eating their livers
out of the white sharks but yeah they
liked their liver right mm-hmm why do
they like to deliver so much minerals
full of minerals yeah because you know
your liver acts as the filter for the
body basically and so it's it's pretty
well known that big predators orcas
leopards lions you know everything they
they like to target the liver yeah and
it gives them lots of minerals that
otherwise they can't get from flesh I
was watching a documentary on wolves and
there was one of the ways that the Alpha
establishes itself that when there's a
kill it's the first to eat the liver Oh
interesting yeah and there's a guy who
was living with these wolves and he was
like tricking them that he was a wolf
and one of the ways he would do it was
he would eat a liver in front of them
and [ __ ] yeah and and then the guy went
away cuz he's a wolf expert and he went
away because there was a farmer that was
having issues with wolves and they were
trying to figure out a way to get the
wolves to leave his livestock alone so
what they did was they set up a speaker
system so they put these gigantic
speakers up and they started
broadcasting these aggressive wolf howls
to let this other wolf pack know that a
new wolf pack had moved into the area so
this guy was on this project for several
months and he came back to the original
wolf pack that he was like conning into
things and the new Alpha had taken over
Oh new alpha was threatening him and so
he had a whimper and knee like he was
like really in danger of being torn
apart by a wolf and on camera he's
inches away from this wolf and it's
bearing it's teasing you know I mean
he's with real wolves right right and so
this guy is like curled up in a fetal
position and whimpering and putting his
paw out like this and this [ __ ] wolf
is baring his teeth just inches from him
huge bumps just here 50-pound wolf like
inches from him just ready to tear him
to shreds
I think they kill each other all the
time oh yeah yeah
in u.s. no no it wasn't in the US I
don't remember where it was but it was
really weird like this guy's life was so
strange because he was in for a long
period of time when he was like running
his research was living with Wolves so
he's with them you know he's a part of
the pack was he I gotta ask you this and
don't answer it if it's uncomfortable
that I've in my field working with
specialized experts a lot like him
obviously that's a whole nother level
mm-hmm
they start to take on characteristics of
these animals I've noticed so like I
worked with a guy who was a bear expert
right and he spent his whole life with
bears and this this man was basically a
bear do you know I mean he was grumpy he
was cranky was big he was hairy like
every part of him seemed like a human
bear I'm wondering if this guy was like
that was he had he started to did it
seemed to you like he had started to
like kind of lose touch with social
norms and he was starting to take on
traits of a wolf that's a good question
it's hard to sit yeah this is the guy so
this guy is this the guy documentary
from 2007-8 called the wolf man yeah I
think this is it yeah so so they're like
Jesus the way they threatened each other
yeah you know I mean so so he would have
a kill and he would drag it over and he
would eat the liver in front of them and
so by doing that he would trick them
into thinking he was the [ __ ] see he's
got the liver and tell me tell me that
guy doesn't express Wolf's character
it's like look at his body language and
every I know he's doing that
intentionally for the animal but to me
that guy looks like he thinks he's a
wolf look at that I mean that's insane
how did the cameraman able to get this
close and they're safe too
very good question hey look at this guy
he's little guy out of his [ __ ] mind
yeah that's my bro you're made out of
jell-o you know you are literally a
water balloon filled with jello and
you're hanging around these super
predators it's not I love wolves they're
one of my favorite animals on the planet
I just think they're so fascinating and
now that they've been reintroduced into
the West you know I I know look at that
like it's growling that thing's kissing
them to show that submissive so he's
eating the liver in front of it have you
ever been to the wolf sanctuary out here
in Pawnee
oh no hurts
know if you ever want to go let me know
I would love to there it's in credits
you know that they don't do it for like
the general public but they rescue
Wolf's and wolf dogs and rehabilitate
them and a lot of times they've been in
fights and they've you know come out of
terrible places and they've got a few
animals that they're they're very
closely related to fully blood
full-blood wild wolves and you can go in
and interact with them you're not
petting them it's not a puppy you know I
mean they don't behave like a dog but
you can go in and have one come up and
approach you and sniff you and it's a
pretty fantastic experience really I'd
like to go let's do it let's do it I'm
in I'll set it up
yeah not doing with that [ __ ] doing
what I was saying is that you know since
they've reintroduced them into the the
West there's been a lot of controversy
behind that and there's talks about
doing that in Colorado and people are
really freaking out like ranchers are
freaking out like hey there's a reason
why everybody killed these things off
right
like don't [ __ ] bring them back cuz
you know there was another surplus
killing that they found I think in
Wyoming where they just wiped out a bunt
like they'll just go ham and kill like
you know 1415 elk cows just because they
can it's a eat them there's a term for
that it's hen house syndrome have you
heard of that no so it's basically like
when a fox gets into the henhouse they
like they get in this like killing
frenzy state where it's not like they're
gonna eat 30 different chickens but
they're gonna kill everyone because
they're in this state right I don't know
that's necessarily the case for that but
um it's it is scary to think of an apex
predator like a wolf getting into that
henhouse type syndrome killing 30 elk
just because they can yeah but you know
what's really interesting Joe is um if
you look as I've done a little bit of
reading on this if you look at how many
instances of wolf fatalities there are
in North America for humans for humans
it's like two or three it's some very
very low numbers there's one in Alaska
like a couple of years back there was a
woman I think through that jogger and
there's one other one yeah and that's
kind of it
you know that's documented however I
have a friend who actually shot an elk
in BC in British Columbia and they
didn't know
but the elk expired right next to a Wolf
Den Oh what and the wolf's tried to
claim the elk they like came out and
said over it he and the guide that he
was with had their back to a tree and
they shot and killed three attacking
wolves and he killed two of them with a
bow and arrow and the other guy killed
one with a rifle and they were like
almost out of bullets and he had one
arrow left and they're surrounded by
wolves
but they had killed enough so you know
wolves they do this they do like a roll
call they howl when they see who
responds and they realized that they had
lost three and so they bailed and they
took off out of the area but they were
in the den he said there was bones in
there and they realized like that they
just were hunting and they'd shot an elk
and it just happened to be right right
where the Wolves had a den to have one
of the skulls at home on my desk of the
wolves yeah oh wow yeah bad stories nuts
when John tells the story John Dudley
yeah there's a video that you watch on
YouTube
okay and he's telling the story it's
like it's like you know you could see
him like going back to the moments
[ __ ] crazy it sounds like a scene out
of the gray yeah they're like in the den
in the den yeah like I spend my life
working with animals that are considered
dangerous and there's wolves bears
there's a handful of others like you
just don't want to be in that situation
obviously it wasn't intentional but it's
just like it's just a no-win situation
we had Glenn Villa knew from that show
life below zero oh yeah I know the show
yeah and he was on the podcast recently
and he was talking about the time that
he got chased by wolves
okay and this was also on camera like
he's got video footage of this and
photographic footage of this where he's
living in this little tiny Shack that's
right next to a lake and these wolves
had killed a moose and they were in the
middle of this frozen lake there was 20
of them was in a huge wolf pack that's
enormous that is an enormous wolf pack
yeah get all the photos of this all on
his Facebook page see if you can pull
that up pull up Glen villain when he
wold yeah yeah it's on there's there's
John Dudley with one of the wolves that
he killed that was trying to do to kill
him yeah steal his elk they were running
at him they were running at him full
clip
shot two wolves that were running at him
Wow he said they were charging out in
full clip and he's at full draw in his
lap he kills one and then another one
comes running down bang they killed that
one
he only carries a four arrow quiver
right so he had one arrow that he killed
the elk two arrows that he killed wolves
on our left and he's got his back to a
tree and the guy he's with had three
bullets she's no sidearm nothing they
were just elk hunting right you know
they're like [ __ ] jeez yeah so um see
this Glanville a new pic so he's got a
series of amazing photographs okay that
he took from his Shack and they chased
him they chased him back to his cat he
got close to them like within you know
100 yards or so guys take photographs
okay and they started circling him and
looking at him and then and then he
starts backing up and they start
trotting and then he just runs and they
run to the [ __ ] door of his cabin and
this happened twice and then he got a
rifle and just start shooting him god
they were running out of me he shot
three of them turn it I mean I don't
know the situation but turning your back
on a pack of wolves and running I mean
maybe they were ready red vine Singh I
don't know but that just sounds terrible
yeah acting like prey is a good way to
get killed yeah I mean he's a really
wise man yeah and really understands the
woods in nature as good as anybody but I
think he was one of those situations
where he knew he could get back to the
cabin and if he didn't get back to the
cabin the way they were approaching him
if they were getting closer and closer
look at that oh my god not amazed that's
that is a phenomenon in itself you don't
see packs of twenty wolves yes I was
saying that one of the like largest
documented packs in that areas was 18
right is actually bigger than that and
they had a moose down so they had this
moose down a moose calf down in the
middle of this frozen lake that guy is
so interesting that yeah I've really
loved the podcast with him because you
know he had just decided like I want to
try to live like as close to nature as
possible no vehicles
nothing just snowshoes and a rifle
living in a tiny little cabin eating
nothing but meat really not just what he
eat like that yeah Wow and you know get
really close to starving at one point in
time that's when I started this is what
it looked like it says 2004 yeah so so
he I'm familiar with the show but I
haven't actually watched it he's on
life below zero he was Scotch he didn't
get along with them gotchas you know
he's a really unique character and I
think they had a hard time with his
uniqueness sure he he's out of all those
people on that show he's living the
weirdest life right because all the
other ones are like oh they have sled
dogs and you know they gather salmon for
their dogs with a you know one of those
salmon wheels and then they you know
they have a cabin and they have a fire
in the cabin and then you know they're
living and they're eating dinner there
are plates and [ __ ] like that
not him man he's he's living in this one
little shack that he built himself he
everything he's eating is food that he
shot and killed walking around Wow
he stole caribou from a wolf why a wolf
kill the caribou and he ran up and stole
it because he was starving I mean this
like neighs and guys living as close to
wild as you could possibly get other
than the fact that he has bullets and a
gun and some and but even he starts
fires he wasn't using matches to start
fires cuz you could run out of matches
but sometimes using like flint and steel
and [ __ ] like yeah what's his motivation
why why does he just want to be closer
to nature like that's it yeah you should
listen to it if you get a chance he's a
really really unique person and just
that he wanted he doesn't have an out he
has an outhouse today he doesn't have a
toilet doesn't have running water today
in Fairbanks so wasn't yeah so he's got
a plot of land in Fairbanks he built a
house there and he doesn't have
Plumbing's like it's too much work all
right you know you got a boat like it
just goes outside and 50 below outside
he's [ __ ] in a hole in the ground
I have so much respect for that I'll do
it for two three four weeks at a time on
an excursion I'm very happy to get back
to a bed and a shower and yeah you know
that's it's that's a whole nother I've
never gone more than seven days yeah
I've done these seven day hunts like the
the one where I got this this mule deer
right here my friend Steve Rinella but
he introduced us to hunting and this was
in Montana and it was October and it got
down to you know it's 9 degrees outside
we're sleeping in these tents and it was
wonderful it was a fantastic experience
really opened my eyes to real wild and
the elderness what it's like to hunt and
and then at the end of these this week
we went back to Billings and we got a
hotel room and I got a shower and I was
like oh my a hot shower after a week in
the woods like yeah that was with Bryan
Callen and me and I was like how it goes
that shower oh my god it's not what you
think most amazing shower ever you don't
appreciate showers now you're getting
them all the time now especially in
California because it doesn't get 9
degrees here right right oh yeah being
outside freezing your ass off and then
but also having the the reward of like
actually shooting a deer and then we ate
a lot of it that night and we're cooking
it over the fire and then you know the
whole trip was done on the the Missouri
Breaks so we're on the Missouri River
and so we took the river 40 miles oh wow
yeah yeah canoes and you know and you
know we had our cargo and all our [ __ ]
in there and we're rowing and so just a
long-ass journey mm-hmm it was pretty
intense
yeah and to go back to civilization
after that it's like you appreciate
civilization because most the time you
don't appreciate like it was a janky
little hotel and Billings but to me it
was like a palace a totally luxury a
television I don't mind if I do
yeah I'm I'm on your page for that I
like returning yeah like decompressing
and then within for me it's like within
a couple weeks I'm like all right ready
to go for the next one you know I go
back to not appreciating the comforts of
home and I'm like ready to go again well
you've probably developed like a taste
for both things right for sure yeah
although like you you're experiencing so
many different facets of life on earth
like you're going to all these different
environments and ecosystems you're in
the water on the land and jungles are on
Islands living man I love it and living
thanks very cool I admire it but it
comes you know like your buddy you know
who got the diseases from the Congo it
comes with its costs like you know we
are in Borneo this year and we were at a
research station in the middle of the
jungle and I don't know enough about B
ecology but it was like
be seasoned and I mean you you should
see some of our videos on Instagram it's
like I'm talking about covered
head-to-toe and B's we were taking like
40 to 50 stings on average per day per
person you know and it this is so
miserable 40 to 50 a day there's eight
hours in a day yeah so you're you're
literally taking stings all day long
well no it's worse than that because we
were only at the station in the morning
or evenings right before waking up or
going to bed the rest of time we're out
in the field not taking stings so you're
taking like 25 when you wake up and like
25 before you go to bed oh so when
you're doing this is there a way to
prevent it is there it like can you use
like a repellent nothing worked we you
know we like put like scarves over our
heads and you know and these one is not
Hornets right they sting you they die
yes but then when we were on that
getting that came in we we encountered
Hornets that put my cameraman into
anaphylactic shock they were so bad oh
great yeah so we it comes with its cost
which I think my point was it makes you
appreciate the comforts so much more
when you get back see that tarantula
hawk and look I did last file I did I
was picking it up right right before you
walked in my buddy Maynard sent me that
yeah
yeah he's got it from Arizona man yeah
that's from his he owns a vineyard and
he a farm in Arizona and he was telling
me about these things and he got a dead
one so it to me they're super cool look
at the size of that [ __ ] its yard and
they come out of holes in the ground
hunter an Chile's like you know there's
yeah yeah it's hello everybody yeah so I
mean the tarantula hawk it's a parasitic
wasp right so it comes out it hunts for
tarantulas it lays its eggs I believe in
the abdomen of the tarantula and then
the eggs hatch and explode out of the
tarantula and that's the life cycle you
beautiful fantastic complicated cruel
[ __ ] it's insane
oh my god I'm sure you've seen the video
of those Hornets that visit this beehive
they visit a honeybee hive and just
start these Japanese Hornet and they
just start chopping off the heads off
the bees no way you know
no I can't believe I'm telling you about
anti-treaty goodness there's a certain
species of Hornets that flies into
honeybees I think it's Japanese Hornets
they fly into these hives of honeybees
and just decimate the honeybees they
kept their heads off with their their
mandibles at the pump chop-chop and
there's so much bigger so they fly in
and there's a slow-motion video of these
enormous Hornets flying in and
decapitating thousands and thousands of
honeybees so what's interesting is the
honeybees they're so outsized I mean the
Hornets are literally like 50 60 times
larger I you see it there they're great
just so maybe that's not the right
number but they're much much larger and
they're much more powerful but the
honeybees figured out a strategy to kill
the Hornets and what they do is they
surround them they get on top of them
and then they beat their wings they'll
all generate heat and then they kill the
the Hornets with the heat of their body
that's unbelievable unbelievable yeah so
here's this thing that's decapitating
everyone in your little village right
and so you have to jump on top of it and
flex and heat it up yeah but the fact
that they were able to devise this
strategy see look how they do it man
they just grab ahold of these bees and
just decapitate them it's unbelievable
they have these horrific faces right
these giant mandibles yeah I can see
that and they're just swarm in and they
just look at them they're just chopping
these [ __ ] honeybees apart you you
said it nature you cruel beautiful [ __ ]
three Hornets versus 30,000 bees do you
know why the Hornets are doing this are
they getting honey we want the larva a
larva yeah yeah they probably want the
larva or they want the honey they want
something but look at all these dead
[ __ ] bees with no heads bizarre crazy
it's not I mean it's it's just so weird
right that that you know that nature
devises these sort of strategies to
prevent overpopulation and that there's
this balance that takes place where you
know the bees are threatened by
something that's very be like so you see
how that
getting on top of them yeah so that's
that's their strategy for for dealing
they all get on top of them so you see a
bunch of them now and he's trying to get
away but he can't fly away and so then
they swarm and then they eventually kill
him so you think that actually like
cooks the wasp something it overheats
their body and it fort see it how many
of them are on there yeah there's
something that it does where it
overheats their body Wow the size the
size comparison there's so much bigger
imagine if you had that Hornet you know
that was six feet long oh my god I think
giant insects would be the worst the
worst yeah the worst I think would be
praying mantises the [ __ ] out of me
mm-hmm we've been on a praying mantis
kick lately watch them kill rats and
yeah everything hummingbirds the
hummingbird one is the wildest one they
sit by a hummingbird feeder I hit
they're not moving and the hummingbird
comes to feed they just just spirit
snatch them it's crazy it's so strong
yeah sighs yeah you know there was one
with a mouse and the mouse is so much
bigger than the praying mantis premiums
just Jax's mouse
it's crazy it's wild it's wild creature
man yeah they're amazing really
cool-looking though I see him all the
time I find them all the time when I'm
running mm-hmm yeah ya know they're
they're amazingly cool and very diverse
you know there's huge ones or small ones
they're spread out all over the world
they're amazing animals what is this one
got a snake makes this is lots of them
it's like a highlight video oh look at
that it's got a [ __ ] snake yeah I
think we can't even imagine how strong
they would be if they were our size now
I think they would run right through
walls oh yeah they would I mean look at
this [ __ ] he's taking on a giant snake
that snake is like two feet long and
he's a little ass huh little ass
pregnant ass and he's [ __ ] it up he's
literally eating it yeah yeah they're
pulling chunks out they're insane and
they have such crazy eyesight and like
they're literally covered in body armor
with their exoskeleton they're just
they're amazing well they seem like what
you would think of as being like a
horrific animal that lives on another
planet totally totally like do you
remember that movie Starship Troopers of
course I love that movie love dydt and
that was one of the things in the
Starship Troopers like these
giant insect gems the bursting out of
the ground shooting stuff out of their
butts and they're great I love that
movie yeah Corre Corre Rico yeah yeah
that was a fun movie right yeah kind of
tongue-in-cheek totally but also like
really gory and totally yeah Neil
Patrick Harris yes like the genius yeah
it's great that's such a fun movie I
mean that's great stuff I said we're
really fortunate those things are small
that all move all insects are small we
would be on the menu otherwise no doubt
about it
like there to like indiscriminately
perfect hunters big big you know
predatory insects is there a history on
the fossil record of enormous bugs like
isopods and things like that but I can't
not that I know of like you know six
foot long preying mantises it's weird
how things sort of figure out what size
they should be yeah just based on what
the environment can support and what
their lifestyle supports like Island
dwarfism mm-hmm
and there's insular gigantism as well
right right it exists in both spectrums
like if there's tons of prey and
something gets there it gets bigger and
bigger if there's not enough resources
it gets smaller and smaller do you know
do you know about the Lions that are in
a very specific part of Africa where the
river branched off and left them on an
island with only Buffalo we discussed
this last time I don't know if was on
the podcast or in the back there but I
that's how I learnt more about it
chatting with you last time I remember
we looked it up there's a great
documentary for people don't know about
it's called relentless enemies mhm and
it's these enormous lines these lines
have evolved to only kill Buffalo so the
female lions are as big as regular male
line it's just yeah I look fake mm-hmm
they look like bodybuilder like what
they do and they just all they do inputs
weird this is what's really weird about
the documentary there's several packs
they live on this island but one pack
has these enormous super lions and then
there's another pack of regular-sized
lines really yeah so since that pride of
the super-sized lions are they dominant
over the other one are they just preying
on different species I don't know it's
interesting I don't know but but I found
it weird that one pack evolved and
became enormous right and then the other
pack just kind of didn't selective
breeding yeah if you're big and jacked
hang out over here and eat Buffalo if
you're
if your winning show over there yeah
it's crazy also is that how recently it
took place mm-hmm that it was I think it
was less than a hundred years that the
officer had switched and that these
animals started to adapt they put on you
know I mean they literally are twice the
size of a normal female lion it's crazy
and shoot but also they're only eating
Buffalo right I bet if you ate water
buffalo every day you just get jacked by
default I'd look like the rock yeah you
its carnivore month guys I think those
things often rise and fall you know and
we're in a state where we understand
what I mean by that is you know so the
river changes you've got nothing but
lines and Buffalo lines get bigger and
bigger and bigger eventually they get to
the point where they wipe out all the
Buffalo because it's not sustainable
then the Lions collapse so what's cool
is that we can actually see that in
action right over over our lifespan we
can see this generational change in the
Lions it might not it might not collapse
it could last tens of thousands of years
but it's interesting that you can
actually see it in taking place it's
it's evolution in action basically
there's a documentary from the BBC about
the Congo that gets into that and they
talk about how quickly the rainforest
had grown and what used to be grasslands
became this enormous dense rainforest
and a lot of these animals that were
plains animals had to figure out a way
to survive right and so they adapted and
they were talking about the duiker
mhm I knee little animal deer looking at
things Wims under water for as much as a
hundred yards and eats fish isn't that
crazy
they've got exactly yeah I mean you just
summed it up it's it's nuts a [ __ ]
antelope that eats fish right and can
hold its breath in freedive God nature
spray nature is metal you have you've
always been fascinated by nature I mean
you you obviously are now and what a
perfect career you have yeah I mean I I
feel like I have the perfect job and I
have from when I was a little kid you
know some so grams embalming my family
on safari businesses that was what we
did but when you're a little kid in the
bush in Zimbabwe you can't just go out
running around you know so you're kind
of stuck in camp so I'd be the one
flipping over logs and grabbing
earthworms and catching snakes and the
way you just said can't
I heard South Africa there
the heart and then it pops out yep it's
the heart is mostly mostly blend in I
try but ya know as I started young and
and just it's just been my my driving
force since I was a little kid that's so
cool yeah well it's such an amazing
subject and there's so much to look at
you will never run out of things to
study never I mean and you never stop
learning look today I learned about the
wasps and the bees like I've considered
myself pretty well read in the field of
wildlife that's all new to me I'm gonna
go home I'm gonna google it I'm yeah
it's just so fantastic it never ends do
you know about the bees and Nepal that
makes psychedelic honey I do yeah I do
and how they harvest that honey yes pull
pull up like some videos or some images
of that these guys are risking their
life to trip balls on this crazy honey
yeah
what are they um what's the pollen that
they're getting it from what are they
getting into I don't have to be sorry
all I know is what you just said which
is it's the the pollen that they're
creating the honey out of that is making
it psychedelic but I don't know there
you go go lick some honey off a cliff in
Nepal and see what happens it must be
really good if you get honey other
places but this honey makes you trip I
wonder what the actual like psychoactive
substance in the honey is no I never
even looked into it yeah what does it
say Jamie but these guys they've
apparently just decided it's worth
repelling bright side of these mountains
because he grows off the side of cliffs
yeah it's like it looks like big like
shelf fungus and like grows out
horizontally off these vertical cliffs
yeah and these as these guys are
harvesting it right they're hanging on
ropes from cliffs getting lit up by bees
and then pop and psychedelic honey in
their mouths now when you speculation on
it was that it may be the higher
altitudes allowed this neurotoxin to
develop called grey and no toxin moves
in it it's called like red honey
specifically well you could buy it I see
diminishes over time so um I gotta get
it fresh right yeah hmm interesting
white Ronin
No Oh wrote it down click on that again
please
we have rhododendrons probably different
family here you know as pretty plants
around California it's just that that's
just a descriptive of the absolute it
might be at that specific one in the
altitude because it stays up there lack
of so it's exported exported from Nepal
to Japan Korea and Hong Kong the red
honey is prized for its purported
medicinal value and intoxicating
qualities and are attributed to this
grey nanotoxin present in the nectar
collected from white rhododendrons the
Gor rung am I saying that right go wrong
people in Nepal are renowned for their
use of this mad economy dude we need to
buy mad huh that's great he's mad honey
for sale see we goodbye mad honey the
name of a band it's a good name that's a
good name it's a great band yeah mad
honey
gentlemen mad honey if they come out
frothing at the mouth yeah there it is I
think no this where's the man honey bro
come on safe I don't want to know if
it's safe I just want to know if I can
get it okay take a chance
bye man honey here we go come on baby
Amazon what do you go there oh god honey
dotnet mad honey from Nepal order that
[ __ ] son 115 grams for how much it was
like 40 bucks up there on the top right
strongest most potent mad honey
available don't look at that Add to Cart
here we go
okay well order something we're gonna
get some man I like that now I'm very
excited I'm very excited we're not live
to because that way that you [ __ ]
out there can't just steal life we would
never have a chance they would sweep up
all the mad honey yeah that's true yeah
like that buy you a jug I'm in we mix it
in coffee next time what do you think it
does to you well I guess would you be
willing to just sit here and absolutely
something organic like that I'm totally
into it
yeah what do you do burr is it
exactly back to Santa Barbara yeah it's
uh it says it's a psychedelic right yes
yeah yeah so I wonder what kind says you
have to be 18 to order it I'm 18 it says
they're mad honey does contain the great
gray a no toxins or otherwise it would
just be regular honey and it is
laboratory tested to assure consistent
quality and it is safe and effective it
says what is effective it's not FDA
tested I wouldn't matter if it tastes
good is it effective right tastes good
or does it make you feel weird yeah what
are you saying he's a make you trip and
how long does it last and also do you
have to eat the entire jar of honey to
feel anything right right anything else
I should know they have not been
evaluated by the FDA these statements
have not been evaluated intended for
education and research purposes only of
course of course dude I'm all about
education and some R&D going on and some
honey over here it's these parts of the
world where people are willing to
harvest things like that like how'd they
figure that out who was the first guy
that's like you see that [ __ ] beehive
up there right I'm gonna get some of
that honey dude right angle off a cliff
yeah good luck my friend saying this the
other day two somebodies
who was the first guy to figure out
caviar who's the first got to suck off a
sturgeon and be like mmm this is
delicious you know good just everything
they can fish yeah and if you catch a
sturgeon man the whole village is eating
yeah I mean so I'm 910 feet long -
they're so bit my friends John and Jen
they live in Alberta and they went
sturgeon fishing and they they caught
them and put them on their Instagram
page and you're looking at like that is
a prehistoric dinosaur right creature
that thing is enormous
those big scales down the sides and down
actually the weird mouth and whiskers
they're bizarre yeah there's something
about the way you you're looking at them
you like I don't feel like you should be
catching that right there's too old yeah
yeah it's like you just should probably
leave that thing alone I think that that
might be one of the you know there's
there's a lot of those North American
things that they think are monsters like
Nessie mm-hmm you know I like the Loch
Ness monster they also have like ones in
Lake Michigan and what do they call it
Lake Champlain they have a Lake
Champlain one and they think that it
might be sturgeon oh and
or see cuz you know if especially
because people have a tendency to
exaggerate if you see a ten-foot
sturgeon you're going to think it's a 25
do you know that um this is kind of
interesting they actually had documented
bull sharks stuck in the Great Lakes yes
I'd heard about the pretty amazing that
is nuts sharks swimming a thousand miles
from you know blue easy Anna up rivers
and getting stuck in the Great Lakes
well they're one of the rare sharks that
can breathe fresh water right katara
--mess yeah so she goes yeah in and out
of in and out of fresh water you know
they go through osmoregulation they can
get the salt out or in whatever they
need and then go into the rivers spend
time in the rivers go back into the
ocean to hunt the inspiration for the
movie Jaws was apparently bull sharks in
New Jersey a series of attacks in fresh
water on a river system right but near
an ocean I believe railing at a river
mouth yeah yeah that was my
understanding yes people were going into
the river and these bull sharks were
killing them right like in a river yeah
no we're safe well they're really
aggressive right yeah they have the
highest testosterone of any species of
shark and so they're just they're just
jacked up yeah they're just ready all
the time like they're they're a bullish
and you know their shoulders are kind of
arched over their pecs are locked and
they just they look ready at any time to
just snap yeah they found them all the
way up and like Illinois yeah yeah it's
crazy [ __ ] like think of the temperature
in Chicago right now you know and the
shark swims all the way up there
cold-blooded monster yeah how do they
get into the Great Lakes well they used
to go up the Mississippi River but I
think with all the locks that are there
now in place they just I think the idea
was that they got stuck there when they
were building the locks and then they
died out over time when when was the
last known sighting of one I think some
two years ago no there you go they find
him is been one found in Iowa Texas [ __ ]
is a shark king - I imagine yeah we lost
Billie got bit by a shark
what was he surfing retinol he was in
Iowa right right he was plowing corn and
got killed by sure there might be an
[ __ ] yeah
I found them really yeah Ohio Chardon
Ohio what how do they get in Ohio all
those rivers are connected yeah ha damn
that's amazing right nature finds away
you know whenever I look at those videos
of bears catching salmon and jumping up
the river like what was the first salmon
thinking when it decided hey I'm gonna
go up these rocks right back to the
place where I was born right and and and
and spawn there put a target on my back
yeah oh just gigantic [ __ ] bear
waiting to catch me in the air right
like those images of bears catching them
with their mouths as the salmon are
flying through the air so I make it up
to it's just but it's so weird like what
a weird system it's like nature's
assuring robustness they're sure
assuring that these fragile fish don't
make it correct in order to be able to
make that trip to the ocean and back to
get through the rivers and streams to
survive you have to be rugged right and
so they're showing it now so they're
going upstream swimming against the
current oh oh and by the way here's a
[ __ ] 1800 pound they're looking to
eat you it's crazy it's so cool but that
that is a viable system is this is the
system that's been in place forever
right so strange right and and that you
know we can destroy that so quickly we
put one dam in and that that ruins that
whole ecosystem for that River and the
Bears and the salmon and the spawning
and you know we can remedy that we put
salmon ladders in and yadda yadda but
it's it's interesting that everything
seems so tough as you just said and at
the same time it's so fragile because we
you know we do one thing like putting a
hydroelectric dam and it ruins the
entire ecosystem yeah we were in Seattle
and in Seattle there's a place where you
can go and it's like underneath this
bridge and there's these clear
plexiglass walls and you can actually
see the salmon the way through and up
the river and they were explaining how
they had put dams in and didn't really
understand the consequences of putting
these dams back when they did and then
all these salmon would go to the mouth
of the river where they thought they
were going to go upriver and it would be
locked right there and he has died and
didn't breed and so the population
drastically diminished these salmon died
in like in the harbor yep like really
wild stuff yeah it's crazy and then
supports you know like that food source
that protein supports not just like the
Bears and the birds but like the whole
river is ecology right like the river
the lg's that live in the river the
little bugs that live in the algae
depend on those salmon dying up that
river and fertilizing the river yeah so
it's like the whole thing is so
interconnected and then you know one
little thing and poof did you yeah that
is really crazy did you see that video
of the octopus that had captured an
eagle that captured an eagle yes it was
in Vancouver Island I know the octopus
had captured an eagle and was trying to
eat the eagle and these fishermen saw
the struggle and released the Eagle from
the grasp of the octopus suits to me is
like that so here it is right here holy
crap that Eagles like [ __ ] out bro help
help
hello will help but to me it's weird
it's like why are you getting involved
in this right it's not like right like
people want to think that Eagles are an
endangered species they are absolutely
not endangered you go to Alaska they're
like pigeons up there they're they're
Giant Pacific octopus they're amazing
those in for yeah but that that's the
thing it's like I kind of like octopus
more than I like Eagles there's much
smarter they're way smarter yeah yeah
they're really interesting I mean I love
Eagles too right but you kind of got to
lay a play out look if I saw like a lion
that that eagle might not make it anyway
look at them right he's [ __ ] he's it
alone I'm sorry water happen what
happened the monkey-people safe and the
[ __ ] and the kraken yeah he was I
don't even know how the octopus got him
but the like what octopus can do is
nothing short of spectacular you know
we're talking about my friend Remy
Warren earlier and he had a show on
television before called apex predator
and it was basically they would study
apex predators and you know
the different strategies they used to be
successful as a hunter and when they did
the one on the octopus he you know he
was in here and like he was like dude
they're from another planet yeah he's
like that is the way they change their
texture right in their color and the way
they do it instantaneously to adapt to
their environment and how well they
blend in they're so interesting I think
they're the most alien creature that
exists on planet Earth yeah I agree
there's a there's a new documentary out
on I think it's PBS called making
contact that's just about octopus
intelligences this guy he's a fisheries
biologist and he gets an octopus and
basically lives with it in his living
room like he figures out that this thing
likes being petted like it knows how to
it's just it's the diverse array of
things that this thing can process
mentally it's like on par with like what
chimpanzees do you know what I mean it's
like it's just like it can open jars it
can close them it can come out of the
aquarium go back into it it'll swim over
if it knows you it knows if it doesn't
like you like it's unbelievable yeah
really weird right yeah dad we got this
video the octopus dreaming I just looked
it up and it starts with the octopus
this is my living room this is it this
is super viral yeah well they apparently
as the octopus is asleep and dreaming
it's changing the outside color and
texture of its skin in relation to
whatever the [ __ ] is going on in its
head right right so wild nuts it's just
so weird how they can instantaneously
change their coloration and their
texture and then perfectly blend in with
coral right like when you see them like
stopped on a coral reef and just become
the reef you like what ardently - it's
like yeah and it's gone the colors in
this thing you know what simcha there
are actual there are people that
actually believe they are from out of
space I've seen that I'm gonna bring it
up to you that there's biologists that
believe that they came in and asteroids
and eggs you got it yeah that's exactly
really think about that I think like
look I believe in life outside of Earth
but I don't I don't necessarily think
that octopus came from that I think
they're you know they have other stuff
like there are other cephalopods that
they're related to genetically squid and
cuttlefish and things like that
I don't necessarily think they came from
out of space but I can see why
there's science to support that it's a
possibility and then I can also see why
people think that seeing them well
there's thoughts about that with a lot
of different life forms like spores
there's thoughts about that when it
comes to psilocybin mushrooms yep
there's like the real freaky psychedelic
heads think that psilocybin mushrooms
came from asteroids right and and the
the proof and the pudding in that one so
to speak is the fact that you can take
mushroom spores into the vacuum of space
and bring them back to earth and there
they still they still fruit yeah trying
to grow a weed right now to see what
happens out there you guys sent a little
bit of weed into something on the space
station I think we're gonna test it for
30 days and see if it's viable really
that's when we get the weed business us
and Elon space weed SpaceX right is
Wheatley LAN cent weed in the space I
don't think this is the first time it's
been done but the story went around cuz
that's interesting because when he was
on here I don't know if the game hailed
no he's growing weed in space look at
what they're the octopus eggs look like
whoa and so they're developing those
intelligent chromatophores that thing
that basically the skin picks up the
color and changes to match
mm-hmm right there in the embryo yeah
look at their little eyeballs how weird
and look how many of them like an
invasion the imagine if your wife gave
birth to that many people no thanks
you'd be like oh I have a school school
full of kids hey first of all I'm
getting [ __ ] snipped look at that
look how they drop off points what the
matrix looks like exactly dude the
matrix is not that far off and it seems
like the further this further we go in
time and human evolutionary time the
more it seems like it's an act it's
accurate you know I think we're getting
more and more plugged in every yeah it's
like a combination of the matrix and the
Terminator together yeah I'm very
concerned about the future of our
species but but going back to octopus
octopus and cuttlefish are closely
related right and they both can change
the texture in their color yeah
cuttlefish have lack less textural
changes they're more color based okay
what was the one they did
would they had him over a chessboard and
it was trying to meet you ever seen that
we're now this is trying to mimic a
chessboard that's cool yeah is really
weird because it throws a system off
because there's any right angles and
it's hard just yeah and the one zero
contrast so when you look at it like
this octopus like trying to like figure
out her right what to do yeah can you
see actual like lines in his color I
don't remember I remember it being weird
is it a coefficient yeah see if we could
see it here it's very strange pictures
good yeah look at that I mean that's
pretty good
like pretty [ __ ] good yeah look it's
got white squares man write the goddamn
things growing white squares started
with zebra stripes and then I think it
maybe it figured out the squares after a
couple that's pretty impressive I like
the picture in the bottom right there
where the guy looks like he's playing
chess against the cuttlefish
I never mind I thought there's a
cuttlefish yeah just what a strange
ability that these animals have
unbelievable figured out I mean just how
the [ __ ] did that evolve right there
they're devising strategies in order to
be more effective predators while
they're in the ocean and hide from other
predators right and they've figured out
a way to change the color in the texture
of their skin like how long did that
take exactly exactly
millions of years yeah this like it's an
endless source of fascination like
wildlife documentaries to me are just
truly an endless source of fascination
there I mean you know you're preaching
to the choir but yeah I think they're
phenomenal you there's just so much we
can learn and it's like it's more than
just what we learned oh that's cool
that's a nice fact about an octopus but
you know we took how we shape Jets off
of the shape of birds we've taken so
much inspiration from nature into our
everyday lives look at this look at this
squid skin squid skin this so squid or
chick oh my god it's like a television
yeah like the pixels on a television I
didn't know squid could do that - oh
this is so weird
oh god they're so strange such a stream
strange animal but the ocean is so
bizarre in and of itself there's just so
many weird creatures on ocean it's such
an alien environment to us as
terrestrial mammals do you remember when
the tsunami hit Thailand and then there
was all these animals that they were
finding that they had never really seen
before washed up on our shores I
remember that yeah yeah and they were
documenting them there was a whole
website dedicated to soon tsunami deep
sea creatures I didn't know that yeah
yes really crazy like some of these
things that are living you know a
[ __ ] mile down under the earth and
you're like what what are you and they
they forget what the number was but they
got like 30 or 40 new species or
something crazy like that literally like
combing through the streets of the
cities where these where the tsunami had
hit yeah is that a richer source of
bioresources of the the ocean of a
biodiversity I should say the ocean then
earth oh there's more life in the ocean
than on terrestrial land for sure yeah
you mean is there more diversity in
general weirdness oh yeah there's way
more I I guess it depends how you define
weirdness but like look at an octopus
look at a cuttlefish you know look at
those deep sea creatures crabs and all
the way into the marine mammals and all
the way down to the tiny little insects
are isopods that live in the ocean I
think I think the ocean creatures are
very bizarre how about those giant squid
that they found on that oil tanker giant
squid with the crazy like crab legs yep
that one legs maybe not never see that
one with the crab legs is he walking
along the bottom no it's got like it
looks like it has appendages well with
the joints yeah haven't seen oh my god
oh I'm gonna show you something I'm
learning a lot today I like this crazy
alien looking squid I found another
thing about those pictures they've been
gone around multiple times after
tsunamis apparently they don't have
anything to do with the tsunami they're
just there are real photographs of real
strange sea creatures they just didn't
washed up on shore after tsunami what
about the thing that you'd saw that's
what I said when I was her 2004 in 2011
the same photos also people are
bullshitting Russians believe me
go to pull up that alien squid
discovered near oil rig so they had a
camera deep under this oil rig and they
spotted this thing with these insane
long appendages look at this oh whoa
yeah that's different
I thought you look at the [ __ ] length
of those what are those things that
dangle from it what do you would you
call those things let tentacles legs
what is it but look at the legs on it
like an insect that's very bizarre see
how they have like very like obvious
bends video courtesy of shale oil
company doing a good job for nature yeah
right I see the deep there's another one
is that another but look how weird it is
how it has like a clear bends like when
you see that thing underwater floating
around like that like that looks like an
alien
totally totally that is that is our
exact kind of depiction of what an alien
species go to that green one right next
to it oh yeah look at that like look at
that that's crazy I mean if you saw that
underwater you would [ __ ] your pay $150
but that the length of the actual
tentacles whatever the [ __ ] it is was
really long so strange
and this before they got this video
footage of it they didn't even know
something like this was real and there's
there's like a lot of those where you
get these deep-sea cameras and you're
like oh there's a species we haven't
ever documented before so it's in the
Gulf of Mexico they caught a depth of
seven thousand eight hundred feet but
they did what does it say how big they
think it is you can just type in 9 mag
fins magnet weena the squid size just
big big fin like a [ __ ] just so weird
it look like the way that the head of it
sort of pulsates and moves with waves
like it's like a Steven Spielberg
creation yeah yeah that and then there's
also a puppy right you know that's how
diverse life is okay
length is up to 15 to 20 times the
mantle 20 26 feet okay that's one more
or more yeah well giant octopus is -
right giant squids were thought to be
[ __ ] until like fairly recently rekt
yeah I don't know when specifically but
they've found a few that have washed up
and then they got some they got some
actual footage of some that's what I
thought you were talking about on some
rigs easy
what about octopi what's the largest of
the octopi the Giant Pacific octopus so
the species that you saw attacking that
eagle
that's not a huge one but as far as as
far as I know that's the largest one the
[ __ ] yeah that's a giant squid it's a
big cephalopod oh that thing's huge that
looks like it's more than 28 feet if you
stretch that [ __ ] I know those ones
those ones are those ones are like a
hundred plus feet yeah that's what the
giant squid yeah a hundred plus feet
they can get up to that yeah it is so
nuts
isn't it a hundred foot jelly creature
you know and you know what's interesting
is sperm whales will leave the surface
of the ocean and dive down to their
depths to hunt those Calamari's good
look at that [ __ ] so weird
so the the large pacific octopus how big
Giants Giant Pacific octopus how BIG's
that guy get um I don't know and I mean
you know cuz they fan out so I'm not
sure
maybe 5 feet long 6 feet long but heavy
like 40 50 60 pounds something like that
they've got a really big one at the
Monterey Bay Aquarium really yeah really
cool one oh I've been to that I've been
to that aquarium back in the day yeah
The Legend of the Kraken like they used
to think that that was all total
horseshit right until they found some
fossilized cups they found some suction
cups mhm that were the you know some
fossilized evidence of enormous cups
right that they think are indicative of
this you know real hundred foot octopus
or [ __ ] octopus well or just a
hundred foot squid on the surface you
know what I like you said those stories
always get embellished so even if it was
a 60 foot squid on the surface say it
was injured or dying and it was
live and the boat hit it and it starts
slapping the boat with its with its
tentacles haha my tits to crack and like
that's not going to turn into a crazy C
fable to imagine though if you were one
of those dudes that was like making your
way across the ocean and you you know in
the 1100s or some sh a and you jump in
the water to wash off and you get eaten
by a giant octopus in front of your
friends yeah that's it's literally
suction cups that rip you apart oh it's
crazy and it's totally possible that
those things were huge we just don't
have the fossil evidence because they're
all made of jelly right you know they're
just like they don't fossilize yeah yeah
all you get is like if you those
fossilized the images of the the the
cups is just because it left an imprint
writing some sort of soils right at the
bottom so you you like these kind of far
out there ideas how do you like this
idea there is a cut there's a group of
people that say that dragons were real
and I'll explain so it around the same
time period so to speak and I'm not one
of these people so I'm probably gonna
get the details wrong Matthew
McConaughey movie yeah seriously but so
around the same time period in you know
China South America Africa all these
different Rome all these places images
depicted people fighting dragons right
and every every dragon was slightly
different but it was all a giant scaly
animal that could fly so when you take
when you break that down you think about
the fact that large birds had a hard
time being fossilized because their
bones are so porous right so because
bones there have like hollow wishbones
they break down very easily they don't
fossilize so the the group that says
this basically they're they're saying
the evidence is the reason there's no
fossils of dragons is because they had
bird bones and they were actually very
delicate animals but a handful of these
more small a small population of these
giant lip flying lizards existed and
basically encompassed all these
different countries where they all
depicted fighting dragons in their own
way and they were all killed off by you
know Knights or whatever it is and then
didn't fossilize so it's like the
science is saying that if there
or lizards big enough to fly around and
eat people they didn't have bones that
could fossilize so it would be like an
eagle right and so and that's why you
know that's why all these human
populations around the world have
depictions of them because they did
actually exist now are there any stories
of dragons like written like in the
times of people that actually had the
written word or is it just depictions I
don't know not my field that I
interesting because like are these
depictions like ancient accounts told by
generation after generally past so I
think I don't know I don't know anything
about dragons or whether it's real but I
think it's interesting to think oh well
the science supports that if there were
flying lizards their bones wouldn't have
fossilized and these have been passed
down stories that have been exaggerated
and passed down from generation to
generation and some of them breathe fire
but some of them don't Yap upon which
culture it was significant - I wonder if
what the fire with the fire supposed to
represent or they just people are full
of [ __ ] probably that one yeah probably
made it sound even cooler yeah exactly
do you think that do you hold any weight
do you think that holds any way no
actually dragon I mean we know there
were large flying lizards during the
times the dinosaurs right the only
weight that it could possibly hold is
that like a few of those somehow
survived much later than we previously
thought but I do I think that there were
at dragons attacking human beings and
civilizations now I don't but it's still
interesting it's so much cooler if there
were right and the fact that we know
that pterodactyls did exist that's cool
right would be rate way cores that they
existed with people right 2,000 years
ago why is that so much cooler it's like
I would be I would I mean people would
dedicate giant chunks of their life
trying to find out if pterodactyls did
coexist with human beings at a point in
time oh really what absolutely many of
you but there was a hundred-foot
pterodactyl snatching kids be terrified
Oh God would you know about the the MOA
eagle yeah yeah the hasta hasta act like
all MOA you go because they used to tag
Mouse these weren't that big no but they
did supposedly snatched Maori children
yeah but when I googled it I remember
I think the large ones were like 40
pounds or something like that I don't
think they were that but that all it is
yeah can evil is really light right but
their wingspan is so enormous yeah I
mean they're they have incredible power
look I don't see an eagle snatch a
salmon with its claws and fly away with
this 10 pound salmon right and it's claw
minutes insane it is cuz that salmon
probably weighs more than it right right
birds are weird right they sit on you
like oh you're not really heavy no they
don't weigh anything and again that goes
back to that whole hollow bone type
thing right that's why chickens are
strange because they're fat yeah they
weigh a lot like you pick up a chicken
oh you fat [ __ ] but bird like a hawk of
a fairly light yeah for what it is yeah
yeah I think was the biggest Haast eagle
how big was the hostile but they they
were hunted by people right because they
they posed a threat and because people
hunted the MOA to extinction that giant
bird that name heard that the hasti will
primarily preyed on and so the twofold
kind of made them collapse yeah large
gigantic ancient things ate and I have C
wingspan for a female is typically 8 and
a half feet possibly up to 10 and a few
cases live female I'm trying to talk I
just the first thing I see yeah and one
about the big do males 25 pounds females
31 pounds Oh largest female could have
been 36 pounds and mass yeah but still
it big but a 10-foot wingspan is getting
huge Oh huge yeah I mean you know talons
you they've got it I don't know but they
had to have been enormous yes
flying knives yeah well you've seen the
videos that the the Mongols use where
they they train Golden Eagles to kill
wolves mm-hmm yeah crazy son believe
they [ __ ] up wolves like yeah way
smaller than a wall oh yeah the wolf has
zero chance right they swoop down and
grab a wolf by the back of the neck and
just [ __ ] him up isn't it crazy trying
to get away and they just killing them
and I believe maybe it's not Mongolian
culture but one of those you know
falconry cultures you have to like as a
teenage boy or something like that
you're right of passage is to go climb
the cliff and take the check out of the
net
and it's like this crazy process where
you know a number of kids died trying to
get to the Eagle chick and the ones that
come back that's their bird for however
long the bird lives or I don't really
know the hook process right now the
avatar isn't that nuts right yeah that's
bananas I'm gonna steal the chick from
the nest and raise it uh-huh
figured that out who figured out you're
gonna train a [ __ ] raptor I don't know
like how weird are people yeah they
figure these things out and someone was
the first you know I mean someone was
like I'm gonna go get that baby bird I'm
gonna you know what he probably did he
probably got high off that honey climb
and that's here I'm gonna get me a
[ __ ] bird bird do all the hunting
that's like you're crazy man do the hunt
when I was in Venice this summer there
was a guy that had a hawk that he had
trained that was sitting on his arm that
he would stand there to keep the pigeons
from disturbing all the customers that
were eating in this restaurant no way
yeah cuz the pigeons in Venice were so
aggressive yeah that uh this place we're
staying at called the gritty Palace
which is this beautiful old hotel in
Rome or in Venice rather and now it was
like up until really recently the water
subsided but it was up in there like
four feet of water slowly flooding yeah
shit's changing I'm sure there folks
yeah but this guy was standing there as
we arrived with a hawk on his arm and I
think it was an American Hawk that had
trained and just to keep these pigeons
on check because the pigeons to see the
hog foxes what do you send them are you
standing there all day I don't know
maybe did which would have been dope
right I would have loved it to see a
hawk Jack a pigeon while meeting
linguini with clams yeah this is perfect
yeah yeah look at this Hawk Falcons oh
those are Falcons these guys are these
planes they take them on the planes
these emotional support yeah Falcons I
think so
that's hilarious it literally says plane
with emotional support well here's one
with a lot of them on them and
supporting them or be on that flight
yeah listen man I'm gonna wait for the
next flight yeah I'm not flying
with a bunch of [ __ ] birds with
they're wearing masks over their head
they have execution hoods over their
heads it does look like it's so strange
but it's a human's are so weird and our
ability to domesticate and capture
animals but there is evidence that other
animals do it - have you ever seen the
baboons that raise dogs I know what
you're talking about yeah there's a
couple different primates that basically
had pets they steal dogs and then bring
the dogs and feed them and put them in
the camp because the dogs will bark when
things are coming so they can sleep so
they can eat and sleep so the hyenas
just hang out with these dogs the dogs
become like their buddies it's not crazy
but they steal them and they literally
know they're to get this dog and bring
it over here and then feed it right the
dog will be like their guard dog this is
my this is my pad yeah which is what we
think happened with humans and wolves
like which sort of fostered this
relationship with people and dogs
exactly yeah these hyenas have figured
that out isn't that nuts what the [ __ ]
man
however he is figuring that out have you
uh read any ass appalled skis work on on
on baboons I don't think so
Robert Sapolsky is fast any guy he's out
of Stanford and he's I found out about
Sapolsky initially because I became
obsessed with toxoplasmosis
that's that cat parasite that alters the
behavior of rodents and makes them
attracted to cat urine so that they will
they it actually makes the rodents erect
their their testicles and other their
their scrotum in enlarges and engorges
with blood when they smell cat urine
they become sexually aroused by the
smell of cat urine so this makes them
get eaten by cats because the only place
where this parasite can can grow and
breed and reproduce is inside the gut of
a cat so it's crazy
so rewires the rodents sexual reward
system and makes them lose all their
fear of cats not just all their feet
everything comes sexually aroused by cat
urine so they run around and actually
chase cats I can seem Oh cats look like
trying to get the [ __ ] away from these
rats that have talked so that's insane
right so then it gets in the cat
and then it gets in the people okay and
Sapolsky when he was studying he found
when he was doing his residency one of
the doctors is working with was telling
them when they get a motorcycle patient
and check them for toxo because there's
a disproportion on earth is infected
with toxoplasmosis Wow and this
toxoplasmosis Gandhi apparently changes
human behavior and it makes people more
reckless and there's a direct
correlation between motorcycle accidents
and infection with toxoplasmosis and
they think that what happens is look at
this rat this rat is sexually attracted
to this cat so this rat is like running
about on this these cats look at him
he's running towards them they don't
know what the [ __ ] they did look he's
running on top of the crowd
look at his Louise he's on his back and
the cats like what the [ __ ] is going on
I give you this look at him yeah that's
nuts
that's so strange they have their whole
brain is rewired because of this
parasite so then the parasite gets in
people it makes people more aggressive
it makes it it makes them more impulsive
well and they think that that's related
to the disproportionate number of
motorcycle accidents that are connected
to people that are toxoplasmosis
positive so there they have this
infection they just take risks and they
wind up crashing that's crazy dude what
a crazy correlation you know those
together in some countries it's the rate
of infections crazy like in France at
one point in time was more than 50% Oh
what 50% of the population was positive
for toxoplasmosis and they think that I
don't know what the number is now but
they think that in the United States
more than 50 million people know way
more than 50 million people test
positive for yeah and is he everything
turner's like yes cat owners or people
live in rural populations where there's
feral cats Wow and they step in the [ __ ]
and then the [ __ ] gets in their skin or
they eat something that is eaten this
cat [ __ ] or you know the cat [ __ ]
infects the cows right there's all sorts
of different methods of infection but
the thing about it is it's not fatal
right but it does have these mark
behavioural changes in human hosts
massive changes in rodent
nothing to the cat right cat seems to
have no no notice no noticeable change
in doormen havior but the gut of the cat
is where they breed sure no we do since
our cats digestive system right the only
way they get in there is by tricking a
rat to try to go near a cat to hump a
cat yeah what what yeah it's crazy
so Sapolsky did a bunch of work with
baboons and these ruthless vicious
baboon tribes and one of the things that
they found was that these certain
baboons started eating human food
because they they started eating like
these like at dumpster sites and they
got poisoned by you know poison food
like the food was bad or it was infected
with a disease sure and the alphas were
the first to eat right so these alphas
died and so the ruthless vicious bully
hyenas are not hyenas blame the weed
goddamn wheat baboon sorry baboon
populations are the ones that had the
dogs right I said that you you got you
slipped one hyena in there but I got you
I was falling trying to keep up with
biologists so the baboon has raised the
dogs the baboons the Alpha baboons that
Sapolsky worked with were eating this
poison food and the alphas died right so
they were left with a bunch of beta
baboons right and these beta baboons
changed their behavior they stopped
being ruthless to each other they
started grooming each other and it
lasted like several generations so he
would return to Africa to study these
baboon populations right and there was a
complete shift in baboon culture Wow
yeah and he's got this really great
speech on it where he goes into depth
about how extraordinary it is that they
you know we thought this was just how
baboons existed and behaved and they
completely changed right and it's it's
and it's attributed down to one
individual well it's attributed to
several that died off because they were
eating this poison food and then the
ones that remained were like the ones
that used to get bullied to sheriff to
say let's just be cool we just soft
yeah and they became the different kind
of baboon population it's amazing yeah
but they got like really sick and fat
from all the human food that's really
unhealthy there's a lot of that globally
you know these populations of primates
that depend on human food have you ever
seen the famous like obese monkey
there's a famous obese macaque they put
him in fat camp they put him in monkey
fat camp no he's pretty funny was he
eating a human garbage basically but he
there is yep oh my page yeah I've seen
that picture that's real that's real I
forget his name oh my god
yeah so fat oh yeah and look at the one
behind him super fat like they're just
they're just eating human trash and
getting absolutely this is like
someone's feeding them cuz that human
trash first shot up cooked corn that
Warren looks really they are and I think
they've restricted it wherever this was
and it is sad because it's basically a
form of animal cruelty you know you're
just making them enormous but uh it's
bright I mean look at it it's insane
yeah the fat [ __ ] it's got a lot of corn
he's not aggressive towards anyone he
just said yeah monkeys will [ __ ] you up
right oh yeah oh yeah primates or
baboons are terrible I mean they can be
super aggressive and all primates I mean
they're they're sweet by nature but if
you know you're a threat to them they
can be terrible yeah but those little
monkeys will steal [ __ ] from you too oh
yeah steal your phone oh yeah I try to
get it back they'll kick your ass my my
partner in production and I have this
ongoing joke where we say we're gonna
make a show called monkeys or [ __ ]
and it's just a show traveling the world
where monkeys pickpocket and bully
people and like jump on trains and steal
stuff and well they exhibit some of the
worst aspects of human behavior you know
we see how monkeys behave you know how
well chimps you know we love chimps
right chimps are adorable when you see
them in movies or adorable and in
concept but they're absolutely vicious
and ruthless mmm-hmm including to each
other they gang up and they'll do wage
war and they'll go capture a neighboring
chimp and kill him yep now they're
they're brutal they are I mean they're
they're like us they're like a step
backwards from human beings you look at
how they behave and you're like oh if we
had no you know social order no
structure no laws nothing that's this
kind of what we'd be like but what's
amazing is that we coexist
yeah what's amazing is that we get to
see oh this is probably our past right
you know right like what was it like
back when humans like you know Australia
Pittacus we were like barely removed
from monkeys right exactly around with
them like how did we figure it out and
they didn't yeah I mean at some point it
was like oh if we collaborate we benefit
more right and they were like if we
fight we benefit more and it's just kind
of diverged from that well that's what's
interesting to me is how some animals
their progress or their evolution
remains stagnant like crocodiles they're
essentially the same way they were tens
of millions of years ago yep
whereas humans is this market change
over the last half a million years a
spectacular change you know or two
million years ago the doubling of the
human brain sighs yep really quickly
right special special moments in
evolution but then other things don't
grow at all but then you have these
lions that get trapped on this island
they go okay we got to get way bigger
right I think we got to [ __ ] up these
Buffalo's the only thing we can eat you
can't [ __ ] up a buffalo if you're little
right and the bigger survive and those
are the ones that bred I mean it's it's
so interesting to see how this stuff
sort of plays out and that we're
studying it and really over the last
only few hundred years or really getting
an understanding of it even less than
that I mean we're really only starting
to understand it on a big picture now
yeah it is amazing and everything in
between like you said these these you
know crocodiles reaching their pinnacle
of evolution on tens of millions of
years ago and us constantly avoid it's
just it's insane the world the living
world is so fascinating have you ever
seen the video of these people they're
in a crocodile park and they're feeding
these crocodiles and this lady's like
Chuck and chickens like chickens out oh
yeah and then one crocodile bites the
other crocodiles leg off and does the
death roll note like I'm straight even
moves mm-hmm this is like leg comes off
and just was like what the [ __ ] bro yeah
it doesn't even move it doesn't react in
pain just nothing I know the exact video
telling I went totally viral yeah he
just rolls and the leg just pops right
off and it was wallows his foot swallows
his buddy's foot like [ __ ] a it's
it's not it's not absolutely not so that
is a cleanup machine yeah that's a 65
million year old cleanup machine yep and
they figured out
this is a great it's like a hammer yeah
you know how to make a hammer right
right there's no new hammers exactly
right hammer is like this is it there's
a stick and then the end there's a metal
thing and bang bang bang
yeah hammer that's a hammer and it's a
perfect tool yeah it's perfect yep I
mean there's bit different sized hammers
you got a came in yep you got a Nile
crocodile exactly right that is a very
good analogy I'm gonna use that the next
time that someone asks please do explain
that because that's genius it's this is
a hammer it's like they nailed it
there's no reason to make another knife
not your knives right sharp edge handle
the bottom got it right it's exactly
right now I love crocodilians I think
they're just so interesting I don't know
if I told you this story we when we were
in my anmar we were retracing the ramree
massacre you familiar with the ramree
massacre no you'll love this so during
World War two
when the Japanese were holding ramree
island in Burma Myanmar the Allies came
in and started making the Japanese
retreat in the course of like two days a
thousand Japanese soldiers were eaten by
crocodiles by saltwater crocodile yeah
so they were retreated days days I mean
some reports say it was over a couple
weeks but the general consensus is a
thousand soldiers were eaten by
crocodiles in a very short amount of
time and it was this kind of perfect
storm of situations where because there
are all these soldiers they were eating
all the prey all the crocodiles were
particularly hungry because of that did
when the Allies pushed all the Japanese
back into the swamps you know they
started screaming and one scream would
trigger all the others just like all the
crocodiles to get into a frenzy and it
just wiped out this entire populace of
people that ran through the swamp so we
went to retrace these steps to figure it
out we're like why did this happen to
try and understand it better and while
we were there this kid got attacked by a
crocodile that was a hundred years old
so probably the same animal that had
eaten people during World War one or one
of them right and we we saved this kid's
life like we got to the village and he
had just been pulled out from this croc
attack his arm was broken in like 25
places he was torn up he had lacerations
all over his leg his ankle his arm and
we should get him out of the
girl's mouth we didn't so he fought off
the crocodile basically and then the
buddy he was with fishing pulled him
into the boat and got him back to the
village what a savage that kid is cut
off a [ __ ] crocodile and a big one
how did he do it
we don't know we were so focused on
saving the kid because myself and one
other guy had medical training so we
were stopping the bleeding and bandaging
him up and we had the only speedboat
because we had to get to this island and
this is very very remote so we got this
kid on the speedboat and got him back to
a hospital and he lived I think he lost
the arm but you know he was just going
to bleed out and die right there in the
village a hundred-year-old crocodile
there probably was one of the crocodiles
that ate the Japanese people during the
massive Ratan remark yeah god damn it my
friend Jim shocky was in Africa and they
had hired him to hunt crocodiles that
were terrorizing this one village these
people had fenced off this area where
they could get water and clean and do
deuce and crocodiles had figured out a
way to get through that and and everyone
in the village had like a bite mark or a
missing hand the bite on their head like
the so many people had lost loved ones
and friends right while he was there a
woman who was washing clothes got killed
by a crocodile while he was in the
village and these are Nile crocodiles
right enormous you have a 20 foot long
plus huge killing machines and these are
you know I try and dispel anybody that
says to me oh these animals were hunting
people and I'm like no they were not
crocodiles are do you know what I mean
crocodiles will hunt human beings they
will lock in outside of a small village
or an area that someone's collecting
water they'll spend weeks watching
studying the pattern learning the
behavior and just wait for the perfect
time where they can sink under sit right
there waiting for someone to gather
water in my opinion they're not
distinguishing that from another prey
animal they just know this thing's
coming to water here at this pattern and
they will absolutely target people 100%
they don't care if you're a person
that's a weird thing about people we
feel like we have some sort of a deal
right well not really after you sharks
aren't after people yeah yeah you have a
treaty with sharks
like are you talking about man you know
like people have this weird thing about
animals you know and you know when
animals find out how easy we are to eat
yeah then it becomes a real problem yeah
I mean Lions of Tsavo right those famous
clients they were they were smart people
it goes to the dark that's a great movie
fantastic movie yeah people they knew
that people were easy prey and they're
like cool we're gonna keep eating him
once they get a few meals like not bad
[ __ ] really easy to catch yeah the
opposite of fast food with like muscles
growing on the beach yeah yeah there's
you know about the Sunderbans in India
yes that's a crazy place crazy I I did a
bit about that in my act as well about
in 2009 my Comedy Central special we're
over a period of 200 years they think
somewhere in the neighborhood of 300,000
people have been killed by Tigers in the
sinaitic bands isn't that nuts I mean
it's just like that that number it's all
its unfathomable there was a story that
I talked about in my in that set where
there was a boat filled with five guys
and one tiger swam out to the boat
killed a guy dragged his body to shore
jumped back in the water swam out to the
boat
killed another guy did it with three
different guys until he got tired of
killing people
that's insane killed three people in a
boat of five so there's two guys lost
three install [ __ ] in their pants
they swim yeah oh yeah this is crazy and
what's crazy about the sunder Barnes too
is there's saltwater crocodiles there's
Tigers there's bear I mean there's the
elephants yeah there's Asiatic Sun bear
there it's just like it's just got it's
this crazy little habitat and I know a
couple photographers that have been in
there and they're like you don't see
anything it's like huge tall Tufts of
grass you know everything can hide
perfectly and it's all there and you
just don't see it coming oh [ __ ] and
bunch of people that are living in these
huts and yes villages they have no
protection but you said something
earlier today about how your friend
projected the wolf howl into the my
friend that guy in that oh sorry that
that weirdo
the wolf expert but what I I love I find
that those non-conflict mitigations are
going
be the wave of the future right using
technology to come up with bio controls
like a wolf growl to other wolves or you
know an alarming sound or a smell that
animals don't want to interfere because
of territories I think that stuff's
fascinating it is yeah I agree
it really is interesting and I think one
of the cool things about all this
wildlife is that if we handle it
correctly we can make sure that these
things are sustainable and they stay
around we can we can still be like just
marvel at their presence yeah and and
you know this it's it is possible to
keep wolves here yeah it's possible to
keep grizzly bears here it's possible to
keep all these things here and we really
really really really should because if
you go back and taught me how amazing
would it be if we could go back in time
and see saber-tooth Tigers incredible to
be able to see some of these animals you
only see depictions of where you see
skulls of you know they were caught in
the La Brea Tar Pits or something like
we have those things right now we hide
now a lot of them and we can save them
and we have the the knowledge the power
the technology the tools the finance we
have all the pieces of the puzzle to
make it work well I think that's one of
the really cool things about what you do
is you you broadcast all this stuff and
you let people know and you have a big
signal and you show people all this cool
stuff like that tortoise that you found
or like all these other different
animals and you let people know like
this is this is interesting this is
exciting this is and it's something that
it's like it's in our DNA to be
fascinated by other life-forms right and
it's worth saving ya know like like we
don't want to be sitting here you're our
great-grandkids Joe sitting at the same
table you know a hundred years from now
going man imagine if we could have seen
a grizzly bear yeah you know like we
don't want that well we still have them
here in California it's in our state
flag it's in our flag the golden grizzly
yeah but there's not a single one left
now there's they killed all those
[ __ ] yeah possibly I don't want to
get down a weird rabbit hole here
possibly in Mexico the silver is easily
bear in the high high Mexican Sierras
what's ongoing reports of Grizzlies so
the same species that would have been
here right that hung out in the Sierras
traveling all the way down into the
Sierra Madres of Mexico and then in
these what
they call sky islands if you're familiar
with that term I'll explain in a second
these islands of isolated habitat up in
the sky where they get more rainfall and
everything else there's there's big
tracts of private land down there in
Mexico where a couple of these farmers
are like something's killing my cattle
and it's not a mountain lion and it
could potentially be like half a dozen
Mexican grizzly bears couldn't be
getting Jaguars though could be but
they're saying it's not cats there's
like reported sightings of seeing bears
real and if you look up the Mexican
grizzly bear you know is declared
extinct 20 years before the another one
was killed so like now they're gone
they're declared extinct than 20 years
later some guy shoots one Google Mexican
grizzly bear I need to see this so which
set I'm trying to find something like
this just shows pictures of grizzly
bears if so you can add the word silver
my silver do they think it's just the
fur color oh they have like a silvery
color to them like hard to tell what
those are real stuff that's in Chicago
but they're from Mexico yeah so what
year is this
that's probably world fair time I don't
know Wow 99 that says but take a look at
winter the last one was killed and then
if you if you can find it see where it
says they were extinct and it's many
many years later parade of some sort
whoa look at that [ __ ] 1960 nineteen
sixties yeah interesting so it might be
possible that that thing is still alive
somewhere there are reports floating in
and I mean the 60s it's not long ago
right so you know there's reports that
on these giant tracts of private land up
in these mountains there's potentially a
very small population of Mexican grizzly
bears Wow
which I think's fascinating and it's one
of those things that I don't think it's
like so crazy I don't think anybody's
gone and looked you know what I mean
like if some rancher who owns half a
million acres in Mexico is like yeah
I've got a bear killing my cows it's
like sure you do right but maybe he does
like who's gone to investigate up in the
high mountain peak areas of this million
acre ranch well there's
not supposed to be grizzly bears in
Colorado but my friend Adam Greentree
who is a very experienced outdoorsman he
was hunting in the San Juan Mountains
and he got a grizzly bear filmed Noah on
camera he's looking at it through a
scope and he documented it on his
Instagram page and he's like that is a
[ __ ] grizzly Wow there's a and
there's sightings of them from the path
that was when he was getting chased by
one but that was in I believe that was
in either Idaho or Wyoming places were
they're known about grizzly bears his
sighting of this is when he's like he's
holding up a gun and a female kept bluff
charge him see her standing there in the
background oh yeah she's not happy not
happy [ __ ] his gun not right it wasn't
no his gun he had the wrong caliber
bullet and his gun so it didn't really
load all the way into the pistol and he
didn't know that until after this
altercation so even if he had like
pulled the trigger nothing what happened
right no bueno but she bluffed charged
him she got within like 30 feet a couple
of times yeah did I uh did I show you
that that lion that we were extracting
DNA from and Zimbabwe did I tell you
about this I don't think so dude this
was pretty nuts so in late last year I
was tracking this giant lion that this
friend of mine had told me that he'd
seen in this in Limpopo Valley of
Zimbabwe like just north of the south
african border and we surmised that
there was a potential that this animal
because it was so big it had such unique
behavior in the fact that it was hunting
Buffalo and even even juvenile elephants
might have remnant Cape lion DNA in it
because the Cape lion was his extinct
subspecies of African lion it was bigger
than your regular lion and they would
follow the elephant migrations north and
then back south but generally they hung
out in South Africa anyway long story
short we wanted to test the DNA of this
lion to see if it had any Cape lined DNA
in it and it was this one individual
animal so we tracked it for over a week
hung bait every night you know did the
collars did everything that you do to
get a lion in and then finally this
massive black Maine lion came in and I
darted it from about
thirty feet away from a block yeah 30
feet but wait it gets worse I was in a
blind so I felt kind of safe right but
when I hit it I had dosed four and it
wasn't even me we had a vet with us he
had dosed for a regular-sized African
lion so the animal takes off running as
we hit in the head in the back recorders
we should you know trot after it on foot
looking for it
and we get up to it we're like oh he's
down okay time to do our work up and I
start walking up to it to check it as
you do when you've tranked an animal I
get Joe from me to that to that
television the big one right there and
it pops up is like hello it's not all
the way asleep and I just dropped to the
ground and just go dude just go limp
right because I'm like crap this is he's
gonna come and kill me and fortunately
he was drugged up enough even though he
wasn't asleep to just kind of like not
know where I was and like didn't really
charge but growled and came forward a
step or two and then kind of turned
turned off and laid back down again
there we got another track into him and
he went to sleep but it was really scary
how big was he I think there's a did you
want to show them the picture on my on
my page huge I mean I don't know lion
weights or points or you know any of the
hunting stats but but unusually large oh
yeah biggest one I've ever seen and I
grew up they're huge
did you get the DNA and did they run the
test we did and there was a 14%
discrepancy no it's not this is the
tortoise actually oh yeah why they're
earning that no I think this is just an
ad and I just sorry I just used the line
and scrolled down a little ways keep
going down you got a [ __ ] awesome
Instagram so cool you got so much cool
imagery yeah that's a little fur yeah
it's further down I'm sorry I don't mean
to make no worries but it was huge I
mean it was it was just you you'll find
it it's down if he says there was a 14%
discrepancy between it and regular South
African lion DNA so there's something
off so there's something off so we
couldn't quite figure out what it was we
drew blood we took hair clippings and
the latest is you know it's not again
I'm not a geneticist but the latest is
that sample has been sent down to South
Africa to run against Cape Line DNA to
try and figure out what the discrepancy
is but
yeah there was a discrepancy so there is
something unique and unusual definitely
something unique and unusual got it
there no it's uh let me see if I can
find it but um how long ago do you think
this image would be what do you mean
like a year ago yeah no it shouldn't be
that long ago she'd be just a couple
weeks ago because it only came came on a
couple weeks ago let's see if I can find
it quickly it's a big big animal and
I've got on my phone otherwise I know
this is boring for no you ever saw that
it's just this massive lion and to have
him charge me on foot it was pretty
terrifying so you're talking about
something that's twice the size of a
normal one I would say like one yeah
yeah twenty-five to fifty percent larger
I mean the paws were just it's just yeah
I'll show you on my phone I can send it
to you guys but it's just huge huge okay
a black mane unbelievable animal we'll
get you to airdrop it to Jamie sure if
you got the image yeah I got it here
sorry Jane maybe maybe I didn't end up
putting actually yeah that's the first
line I see yeah yeah sorry about that
you might not put it on Instagram is
that even possible in this day and age
well you have so much cool [ __ ] on
Instagram you probably forgot I I did
lose track yeah I mean your Instagram is
just all like crocodiles so much so much
wildlife it is it's lots of fun here we
go I got it here
where did you eat that food that you
sent me you sent me a picture of some
delicious elk that you were eating dude
so the elk came from remember we're
talking about hex technology those hex
guys are friends of mine that created
that technology and I've been I've
tested in the field I'm wearing it in
these lion photos and you're good Jim
I'll just give that to you whatever you
like explain to people well hex I
actually use that when I hunt now -
particularly inland I guess ish so it's
a screen that keeps animals from
recognizing your magnetic signal right
exactly right you think a 100 percent
thing that's real I completely believe
in it especially for certain species
sharks birds that are know included
water and water it's like almost a
hundred percent yeah and you can measure
it right like you
get a meter that that bought that
measures the body's electrical impulse
put hex on and run your arm over it Ryan
eater doesn't move but what is it what
is the mechanism I go oh my god so
that's when he's tranked yeah so that's
it see the darn is back oh that's just a
picture of a picture but that's this
time he pops up when we go to China my
god dude he's so big huge huge and
there's some pictures you'll see in a
second of him on the ground when we're
doing the workup is that him right there
yeah putting a collar on him Jack I mean
just a massive massive animal do you
guys know the size of his sack yeah he's
hung Jesus guys know how old he is um we
didn't actually look into that I'm not
sure I'd be fascinated by that yeah so
this was crazy but keep us informed on
yeah that discrepancy turns out to be
yeah it's fascinating you know that work
takes a long time and it travels around
but we've got the sample which was the
main objective so there used to be a
North American lion that was even larger
than the African lion significantly yeah
yeah significantly crazy
yeah and that was not that long ago
right like when the last 15 thousand
years ago or something like that I
believe it was definitely coexisted with
human beings [ __ ] yeah we had lions yep
huge ones yeah and big Plains game and
everything else but um
oh shoot so the head yeah so the the Stu
anyway the hex guys gave me some elk you
know that they had got and hex is that
that technology that blocks the bodies
naturally-occurring electrical energy
and they got giving me some elk and we
were on that foraging trip where I
brought those poor Chinese from for you
yes and we picked porcini and
chanterelles and we had a cauliflower
mushroom and we just made this amazing
stew and I was like Joe's the only
person I know I would appreciate this as
much as I do are you you're headed back
to Santa Barbara tonight uh-huh I've
silk for you I'll take you up on it
any day Eiffel thank you well listen man
we just did three hours yeah it's really
three thirty-five no idea time flies
again 30 ish minutes I know yeah I
really appreciate you man I appreciate
all the stuff you're doing appreciate
your your social media and tell people
again about your show yes extinct you're
alive on Animal Planet
Wednesdays at 9:00 p.m. we travel the
world searching for animals
wrongfully deemed extinct and we're
pretty damn successful that's amazing
bankrupt thank you appreciate you man
thanks you bye everybody and that was I
had no idea
[Music]